GOOD MORNING WELCOME TO THIS
MORNING'S ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE HEARING WE
HAVE FOURTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
HEARING AGENDA INCLUDING THE
FOLLOWING TWO BILLS THAT ARE
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT. AB TWENTY
TWO THIRTY SIX HELLO AND AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE IRWIN.
BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH THIS
MORNING SPECIAL ORDER OF
BUSINESS I WANT TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY HAS RULES TO ENSURE WE
MAINTAIN ORDER AND RUN AN
EFFICIENT FAIR HEARING. WE APPLY
THESE RULES EQUALLY TO ALL
PEOPLE WHO PARTICIPATE NUMBERS
PROCEEDINGS FOR EACH BILL HEARD
TODAY WE WILL BE A LONG PRIMARY
WITNESSES TO SPEAK FOR UP TO TWO
MINUTES EACH WITH UP TO TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES PER SIDE. THE
PUBLIC WILL THEN HAVE FORTY FIVE
MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ON EACH BILL STARTING
WITH THOSE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
CORE HERE IN THE ROOM PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BE LIMITED TO NAME
AND POSITION ONLY. FOR THOSE
WISHING TO PROVIDE FURTHER
COMMENTS WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. IN ADDITION
TO HEARING FROM THOSE HERE IN
THE ROOM TODAY WE WILL BE USING
A MODERATE TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALLING
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AGAIN
THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
IN THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE EIGHT
FIVE. ZERO ONE ONE. ZERO ZERO
AGAIN THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
EIGHT FIVE. ZERO ONE ONE ZERO
ZERO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON TV. IF YOU
WERE CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO
DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL.
YOUR TESTIFYING ON. IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. WITH
THAT WILL GET. SOMEBODY TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT BY MISTER-
MISTER WHEN EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FIRST ALL LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR HELPING TO WORK ON.
THE BILL AS WELL AND WILL I
WOULD LIKE TO ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
SUGGESTED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS. HE'S
ME AND JUST TO CALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE SPECIFIC
AMENDMENT LANGUAGE. WE ADDRESSED
IN THE LEGISLATION AND THE
AMENDMENT WHICH IS THAT OF
SPECIFICALLY THAT THE BOARD
SHALL CONSIDER THE MATTER FOR
THAT IS THE CALIFORNIA BOARD
SHALL CONSIDER BOTH WHETHER THE
LICENSEE DEPARTED FROM THE
APPLICABLES STANDARD OF CARE AND
WHETHER THAT MIS INFORMATION. OR
JUST MEN FOR INFORMATION
RESULTED IN HARM TO A PATIENT'S
HEALTH. MEMBERS WE INTRODUCED
ASSEMBLY BILL. TWENTY NINETY
EIGHT SPECIFICALLY TO HELP
ADDRESS AN ISSUE THAT WE'RE
SEEING GLOBALLY AND THIS BILL
DECLARES THE DISSEMINATION. OUR
PROMOTION OF MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION OF THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC TO THE PUBLIC
AS UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT UNDER
THIS LAW THE CALC IS GIVE ME THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD WILL BE
GIVEN THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
BRING. ACTION A- D. TODAY WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS DR
NICK SAWYER AS WELL AS DR TANYA
SPIRITUS RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL%
. WHEN YOU HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
FORM WHICH MIGHT BE THIS
AFTERNOON BUT I APPRECIATE THAT
AND WHEN YOU'RE READY. MORNING
MY NAME IS NICK SAWYER AND I'M
EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN AND I
PRACTICE IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA BEEN PRACTICING
EMERGENCY MEDICINE AT A LEVEL
ONE TRAUMA CENTER FOR TEN YEARS-
WHEN THE FIRST WAVE OF
CORONAVIRUS HIT IN TWENTY TWENTY
I VOLUNTEERED MY TIME AT
ELMHURST HOSPITAL. WHICH WAS THE
HARD HITS HOSPITAL IN THE
COUNTRY AT THAT TIME. SOMETHING
I CAN ONLY DESCRIBE AS
DEVASTATING- TWO MONTHS LATER IN
NEW YORK- IN JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY A GROUP OF PHYSICIANS
CALLING THEMSELVES AMERICA'S
FRONT LINE DOCTORS LED BY
LICENSED CALIFORNIA POSITION
NAME SIMONE GOLD. HOW THE PROS
PRESS CONFERENCE. IN WHAT CAN
ONLY BE CALLED THE MOST. A
PROLIFIC PUBLIC SHOWING OF
DISINFORMATION TO DATE.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE WAS NO
RESPONSE BY THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY. THERE IS NO RESPONSE
BY THE MEDICAL BOARDS OR ANY
ESTABLISHED INSTITUTION FOR AN
ENTIRE YEAR. AND YOU'RE NOT
YOU'RE A NUMBER OF DOCTORS
WILLING TO BETRAY THEIR OF
POLITICIZE AND WEAPONIZE THEIR
WHITE COATS FOR POLITICAL AND OR
FINANCIAL GAIN. METASTASIZED
THROUGHOUT OUR NATION. IS WELL
COORDINATED AND WELL FUNDED
NETWORK OF DOCTORS PROMOTED ANTI
VACCINE CONSPIRACY THEORIES SO
DISTRUST IN THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
ULTIMATELY THE KOBE NINETEEN
VACCINES. I SEE THESE IMPACTS AT
MY WORK. HE AS AN EXAMPLE I SAW
WOMEN IN THEIR SEVENTIES WITH
MULTIPLE MEDICAL CONDITIONS HE
WOULD SAY I GUESS IT COULD BE
NINETEEN SHE REFUSED TO BELIEVE
SHE HAD COVERED NINETEEN SHE
SAID SHE HAD THE FLU. THEN SHE
TOLD ME THAT IF SHE DID HAVE
CODE NINETEEN I GAVE IT TO HER.
AND THEN SHE SAID I GAVE IT TO
HER BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE MONEY
OFF OF HER ILLNESS. SHE NEEDED
TO BE ADMITTED TO THE HOSPITAL
BUT REFUSED IT. AND SHE LEFT
AGAINST MEDICAL ADVICE I DO NOT
KNOW WHAT HAPPENED HER. ANOTHER
EXAMPLE. IS- A TRAGIC EVENT WITH
A YOUNG MAN IN HIS TWENTIES WHO
YOU WOULDN'T KNOW THAT HE HAD.
AN UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITION
IF YOU HAD SEEN HIM WALKING DOWN
THE STREET. BUT THREE DAYS AFTER
GETTING CO THAT HE CAME INTO MY
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT. GASPING
FOR AIR WITH OXYGEN. OXYGENATION
IN THE SIXTIES LOOK LIKE HE WAS
DROWNING- THAT PATIENT DIED IN A
MY KAHLER MY CARE THAT DAY. AND
DISINFORMATION KILL HIM. IF HE
WERE VACCINATED HE WOULD
OTHERWISE BE ALIVE- THEY'RE OURS
THERE'S TWO THINGS I REALLY WANT
TO JUST MAKE SURE THAT AT THAT
YOU TAKE AWAY FROM THE SAY IN
AND MAYBE MAKE MENTION THOSE TWO
THINGS KIND OF QUICKLY YEAH I
APOLOGIZE NO PERFECT- IS WE GOT
TO STOP THE DISINFORMATION
PIPELINE AND WHAT THAT IS THAT
THESE ARE DOCTORS WHO ARE
LICENSED PHYSICIAN TO CARRY THE
SAME LICENSES I DO WHO PROVIDE
LEGITIMACY TO DISINFORMATION
WHICH NOW IN TWENTY NINE STATES
STATE LEGISLATURES ARE USING TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE DISINFORMATION
. AND WE NEED NO- STATE MEDICAL
BOARD HAS TAKEN ANY ACTION
AGAINST LICENSE POSITIONS TO
STOP THIS. THE SECOND THING WE
NEED TO DO IS ENSURE THAT WE
PASS AB TWENTY NINETY EIGHT BUT
ALSO MAKE SURE THAT THE MEDICAL
BOARD DOES ITS JOB BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A SUFFICIENT NUMBER OF
PROVISIONS. ARE ALREADY ON THE
BOOKS THAT THEY COULD BE USING
TO DISCIPLINE THESE DOCTORS
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRPERSON BERMAN AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DR TANYA SPIRITUS AND
I'M A BOARD CERTIFIED
OBSTETRICIAN GYNECOLOGIST.
PRACTICING IN REDWOOD CITY
CALIFORNIA I AM ALSO THE SPEAKER
OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. HAS OF DELEGATES.
AND PART OF THE EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY AND SEE
MAYES BEHALF AS SPONSORS OF AB
TWENTY NINETY EIGHT. THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
UNFORTUNATELY LED TO INCREASING
AMOUNTS OF MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION. RELATED TO THE
DISEASE INCLUDING HOW THE VIRUS
IS TRANSMITTED. PROMOTING
UNTESTED TREATMENTS. AND CURES
AND CALLING INTO QUESTION PUBLIC
HEALTH EFFORTS SUCH AS MAX
MASKING AND VACCINATIONS. MANY
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS INCLUDING
PHYSICIANS. HAVE BEEN CULPRITS
OF THIS MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION EFFORT. RATHER
PANDEMIC. MISINFORMATION AS
PROLIFERATED WHEN IT COMES TO
COVERT NINETEEN AND WOMEN'S
HEALTH. ESPECIALLY SPECIFIC TO
THE CODE NINETEEN VACCINES.
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBSTETRICS
AND GYNECOLOGY ITS PARTNERS AND
ITS MEMBERS. HAVE WORKED HARD TO
READ BUT DANGEROUS MYTHS SUCH AS
THE LIGHT THAT THE- NINETEEN BUT
- BECAUSE IN FOR. OR THE
CONSPIRACY THAT THE COVERT
NINETEEN VACCINES CAN SHED TO
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE. IMPACTING
THE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. THIS
MISINFORMATION IS COMPROMISED
OUR PATIENTS HEALTH. BY
DISCOURAGING MANY OF THEM FROM
RECEIVING LIFE SAVING VACCINES.
MISINFORMATION MAY HAVE ALSO
BECAUSE. WE SAW DURING THE PEAK
. PARTICULARLY IN COMMUNITY OF
COLOR AND WITH NEARLY ALL RECENT
DEATHS COVERT NINETEEN OCCURRING
AMONG UNVACCINATED PEOPLE THIS
HEALTH INFORMATION HAS COST
LIVES. CMA SUPPORTS THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT OF PROVIDING A CLEAR
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK FOR THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA TO
PURSUE. DISCIPLINE AGAINST
PHYSICIANS WHO FLAGRANTLY
DISREGARD THEIR ETHICAL
PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY TO
PRACTICE MEDICINE IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THEIR PATIENTS WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON BILL
LANGUAGE. WE UNDERSTAND THIS IS
A CONTENTIOUS ISSUE BUT CMA WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW. TO ENSURE THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA HAS
THE ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO PROTECT
PATIENTS AND HAS THE ABILITY TO
DISCIPLINE LICENSEES WHO VIOLATE
THAT PROFESSIONAL AND ETHICAL
DUTIES AS PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DOCTOR AN EXTRA TO GO TO THE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
I BELIEVE WE HAVE LAURA POWELL
AND DR TRACY BETH HOGUE- IN
PERSON TODAY.
GOOD MORNING MORNING I'M MORE A
PAL CALIFORNIANS FOR GOOD
GOVERNANCE IS A NONPARTISAN
GROUP BUT SPEAKING PERSONALLY AS
A LIFELONG DEMOCRAT AND A CIVIL
RIGHTS ATTORNEY I AM DISMAYED
THE DEMOCRATS ARE BRINGING
FORWARD BILLS THAT UNDERMINE
CIVIL LIBERTIES HI I APPRECIATE
THAT THE CAN RECOGNIZE THE FIRST
AMENDMENT PROBLEM PRESENTED BY
THIS BILL. BUT TWEAKING THE
LANGUAGE CANNOT REMEDY THE
PROBLEM BECAUSE IT'S BAKED INTO
THE DNA OF THE BILL. THE PURPOSE
IS TO RESTRICT SPEECH BASED ON
ITS CONTENTS. OUR CONSTITUTION
SIMPLY DOESN'T ALLOW THAT BROAD
INFRINGEMENT ON SPEECH EVEN IF
THE SPEECH IS FALSE AND EVEN IF
THE INTENT OF THE LAW IS
COMPELLING. THE ANALYSIS STATES
THAT THE CONSTITUTIONALITY WOULD
DEPEND ON HOW IT IS ENFORCED.
BUT THE MERE POTENTIAL THAT IT
COULD BE APPLIED IN A WAY THE
CHILLS SPEECH RENDERS IT
UNCONSTITUTIONAL ON ITS FACE
BEFORE IT'S EVEN ENFORCED. THIS
BILL CAN'T BE SALVAGED BECAUSE
ONCE YOU STRIP AWAY EVERY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL ELEMENT WHAT
YOU WOULD BE LEFT WITH. WOULD
DUPLICATE EXISTING MALL. SO WHAT
WITH THE BILL ACTUALLY
ACCOMPLISH. IT WOULD DISCOURAGE
CONSCIENTIOUS DOCTORS FROM
EXPRESSING THEMSELVES FREELY
ABOUT A TOPIC. THAT IS FRAUGHT
WITH UNCERTAINTY DUE TO ITS
NOVELTY. QUOTING THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT. REGULATING THE
CONTENT OF PROFESSIONALS SPEECH
POSES THE INHERENT RISK THAT THE
GOVERNMENT SEEKS NOT TO ADVANCE
A LEGITIMATE REGULATORY GOAL BUT
TO SUPPRESS UNPOPULAR IDEAS OR
INFORMATION DOCTORS HELP
PATIENTS MAKE DEEPLY PERSONAL
DECISIONS AND THEIR CANDOR IS
CRUCIAL. THE REMEDY FOR SPEECH
THAT IS FALSE IS SPEECH THAT IS
TRUE THIS IS THE ORDINARY COURSE
IN A FREE SOCIETY SO WITH THOSE
PRINCIPLES IN MIND I URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI
MY NAME IS TRACY BOB HOAG I AM A
PRACTICING MD WITH A PHD IN
PUBLIC HEALTH AND EPIDEMIOLOGY I
COMPLETED MY RESIDENCY UC DAVIS
I AM A MOTHER OF FOUR AND A
DANISH AND CAN DOUBLE CITIZEN.
IN MY WORK ABERDEEN BUT JUST THE
COVERED PANDEMIC I PUBLISHED
MOLD PEER START PUTTING ONE THE
CDP AND AFTER BEFORE CAUGHT US
ON OUR- RESPONSE. I A FULL
OPPOSED THE TWENTY EIGHT BECAUSE
I BELIEVE IT WILL HELP US
PUNISHMENT THIS. FOR THE CORRECT
I INTO THE CONSENT. THE POOR
CONSIDER THE ANSWER IS A MATTER
IN ONLY ANSWERS BY JUST JIM
ORTHODOX. THIS IS A VERY ESSENCE
THE SITE PROCESS. IN THE VISIT
AXP IN A- TOP. SENSE EACH.
PLEASE ENTER THERE HAVE BEEN
MANY. DURING THE PAST OF THE-
MISTER SHOULDN'T VENTURE EXCEPT
. AS TRUE. WE USED TO THE OF IT
MOSTLY. SPREAD BUT NOW NOTICE.
ARAB FOR LONG BECAUSE OF AND
SPACE HAVE SHOWN TO BE HONEST.
TOLD THAT MASS. LIABILITY
TRANSMISSION WE NOW KNOW THEY
ARE ON REAL DOING THIS SINCE
STILL DO I MASKING JANTSCH
BETWEEN WHL NCDC ONE USING TO
ANYONE USING SIX IS A CUT OFF
WHICH ONE IS MISINFORMATION. THE
BILL ALSO STATES ON BACK QUOTE
UNVACCINATED INDIVIDUALS ARE AT
RISK ARE AT RISK OF DYING FROM
COVE IN NINETEEN THAT IS ELEVEN
TIMES GREATER THAN THOSE WHO ARE
FULLY VACCINATED. BUT THIS- BUT
THIS IS PROBLEMATIC NOT TO FOR.
HEALTH CONDITION IN THE STUDY IT
WAS NOT A RANDOMIZED STUDY AND
THREE PHYSICIANS LOOK AT THAT I
KNOW CANNOT APPLY EQUALLY TO
EVERY PATIENT SUCH AS THOSE WITH
SEVERE IMMUNE COMPROMISED OR THE
WITH A HISTORY OF IT OF IN.
IRONICALLY A PROBE APPROPRIATE
APPROPRIATELY EXPRESSING
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THIS STUDY MAY
BE SEEN AS MISINFORMATION. I
URGE YOU ALL TO HUMBLY COLLEGE
SCIENCE IS FILLED WITH
UNCERTAINTY AND CONSENSUS CAN
CHANGE. WITH NEW INFORMATION.
INCENTIVES BECAUSE- ARE ABLE TO
SPEAK BRIEFLY AB TWENTY NINETY
EIGHT MAY ROB. OF THIS CRIPPLE
FREEDOM ROADING TRUST IN
MEDICINE AND SLOWING VERY IN OUR
- THANK YOU SO MUCH. WORLD ONE
MOVE TO. THE IS THE- AD ON PART
OF THE- TESTIMONY WORTH IS
ANYBODY IN THE AUDIENCE FIRST
WHEN I GO TO THE AUDIENCE HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE TELEPHONE
LINES. WHO WANTS TO ADD A-
EITHER SUPPORT SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION ALL SAME TIME- BUT
JUST A REMINDER FOR FOLKS
BECAUSE I NEVER A LOT OF- HERE
TO MAYBE A PARTICIPANT. PARTISAN
HERE. HER NAME. ORGANIZED IF YOU
WANNA AND YOUR POSITION EITHER
IN SUB. OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL NOW MORE THAN THAT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DR
LAWRENCE FROM I AM A PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
MEDICAL SOCIETY. AS WELL AS A
PASTIME CISCO COUNTY
COMMISSIONER FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO HEALTH OF. OFF OF
FLORIDA. I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER FOR. FIVE MINUTES OF
THE TYPE. AT A DOCTOR ABRAHAM
LOS ANGELES I PRESENT ELECT LOS
ANGELES COUNTY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINETY
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MICRON RIGHT GENERAL INTRODUCED
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND ON THE
BOARD OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION I SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
AB TWENTY NINETY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. DR DANI AB THE
PHYSICIAN PRACTICING IN LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. DR TIM MURPHY
PSYCHIATRIST AND FORMER
CALIFORNIA PAST PRESIDENT THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. BRENT
SPENCER PAP THE CALIFORNIA
PODIATRIC MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STRYCHNINE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERSED IN BATON
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN THE
CALIFORNIA RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
AMANDA PERTAIN AND I'M A CITIZEN
OF BUTTE COUNTY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. YEAH MY
NAME IS CHUCK MEDALS I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND YOU GUYS NEED TO
REALIZE YOU WORK FOR ME IN THESE
AMERICAN CITIZENS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GUYS A LIAR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR. HEY HEY NO THREATS. MY
NAME IS MIKE I'M WITH THE FUNKY
FATHER'S ORGANIZATION ALSO WITH
THE ORGANIZATION CALLED WHO OWNS
YOUR BODY DOES THE WHO OWN YOUR
BODY IF WHO OWN A BODY THEN YOU
DON'T ON YOUR BODY AND THAT
MAKES YOU A SLAVE ORGANIZATION.
AND WE ARE NOT SLATED THIS
COUNTRY. WE DON'T SUPPORT THIS
INQUISITION RIGHT TO BUY MY
ASSEMBLY MAN RIGHT THERE THAT
GUY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE WANT
LOOK AT YOU SIR. I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AND ANYBODY WHO SUPPORTS
THIS BILL WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE UNDER NUREMBERG
CODES THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR OWN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HEY CHECK
IT OUT I NEED EVERYBODY TO FALL
THE **** RULES. GIVE YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL. I
HILDEBRAND ON BEHALF OF VOICE A
CHOICE ADVOCACY AND EDUCATE
ADVOCATE OPPOSING THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M WITH US SCIENCE IS
ALWAYS CHANGING AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE OBVIOUSLY THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS MAX BONEY M. WITH
REBUILD CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE ANTI
FREE SPEECH BILL THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS DENISE AGUILAR AND
COFOUNDER FREEDOM ANGELS AND
REPRESENTATIVE OF LIKE SET AND I
STRONGLY **** OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. TARA CO FOUNDER
FREEDOM ANGELS I ALSO ****
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS RACHEL COULD HAND I'M
WITH NO TEMAS UST FOR FREEDOM
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. MARGIE LLANES MARGIE
LINDSTROM- RESIDENT ANNA
ELDORADO COUNTY. REGISTERED
NURSE AND PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. DEBBIE HARDY I LIVE
IN AMADOR COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. I'M
DOCTOR LARRY BUT DARD AND
EMERGENCY POSITION AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL URGE
YOU TO PASS THAT THANK YOU. NAME
IS KEVIN VANDAM CLASS FROM
HUMBLE COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THE PHONE LINES
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN
OF THE PHONE LINES FOR ITEM
NUMBER ONE ON THE AGENDA AB
TWENTY NINETY EIGHT. AND WE'RE
GONNA TAKE OPPOSITION AND
SUPPORT AGAIN A REMINDER THIS IS
ADAM UNTESTED MONY. PLEASE
PROVIDE YOUR NAME ANY
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF. EITHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU. YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY NINETY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY NINETY EIGHT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KATIE RITTEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ONE SIXTY ON. NINE
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GABRIELLE
INGRAM FOUNDER OF STAND
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE CELL THANK
YOU. NINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS WE WILL NEVER **** TAKE YOUR
SHOT AND THERE IS A GOD REASON I
. OPERATOR PLEASE MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT. NINE FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT I
CAN MARKETS REPRESENTING THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION POLICY
CENTER AND IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE NINE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M
REALLY SURPRISED ABOUT THAT
LANGUAGE THAT WAS USED ANYWAYS
MY NAME IS BLANKA AND I'M
STANDING FOR MENTAL HEALTH
CLINICIANS I'M ALSO PRT OF
STAND UP SACRAMENTO COUNTY
ADVOCATES WHICH HAD MORE THAN A
THOUSAND MEMBERS WE STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU BONTA
. AT NINE THIRTY AM. YOUR LINE
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR LYNN
SILVER CAN BE ATTRITION AND
CLINICAL PROFESSOR OF
EPIDEMIOLOGY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU BUT- NINE FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES TWENTY ONE- UNCAUGHT
YEAH THEY CAN CALL YOU FOR
THIRTY YEAR I TRY SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M
ABOUT THAT PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL AND FORWARD
SPEAKING AT THE INDIVIDUAL I
FROM SUPPORT THE SELF THANK YOU. THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. ANY HEARING TO FROM KENYA
COUNTY AND STRONG UP AS- THANK
YOU. NINE FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING IGOR GROUP ON BEHALF OF
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINE ONE OH ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS TERRY HUME
I AM I'M INDIVIDUAL IS. STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. NINE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LEON
MALDITA AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF PROTECT US HELP
MISINFORMATION AND SOCIAL ISSUE
THAT WE MUST CONSTANTLY MONITOR
AND PROTECT AND PROTECT US THE
FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINETY EIGHT. THANK YOU. SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS VALUE AND
INNOVATION FROM SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
IT. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
OPTIONS FRIDAY WHEN THE
PRESIDENT OF FREEDOM KEEPERS
UNITED AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS SHANNON PRIMER
I'M WITH EDUCATE ADVOCATE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE CELL THANK
YOU. NINE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS DIANE GARCIA I'M FROM
PETALUMA CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. NINE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS NOT I'M SORRY I'M A
MEDICAL STUDENT AT THE UCLA
DAVID GEFFEN SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. NINE ONE OH
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SALLY MASSON LOS
ANGELES RESIDENT I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SEVEN MY
NAME IS BILL SEEING REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTIONALIST
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT'S
CORRECT. THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LAURIE
SKINNER I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SAVE OUR PHENOMENA PUBLIC HEALTH
OVERSIGHT CITIZENS OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AND WE DO
OPPOSE THIS BILL FREE SPEECH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I AM TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JUDITH I AM FROM.
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF
FAVORITES NO MATTER AND HEALTH
FREEDOM THERE IS NO MEANS TO
KEEP THIS BILL AND NOT A
DOCTOR'S OFFICE. A PATIENT THANK
YOU BYE ON TOP. NINE ONE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JENNY GREAT ON A REGISTERED
NURSE AND I'M CALLING. I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. NINE ONE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE BILLION
SECRETARY RESIDENTS STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. NINE ONE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS JOANNA DARK
NEW FROM ALABAMA I'M AN EDUCATOR
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU ROLLTIDE. MY NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO ANTHONY CAP PRICES
SANTA ROSA PREVIOUS MARINES AND
I'D TOTALLY OPPOSE THIS BILL ROB
THANK YOU SIR. NINE SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M SUSAN AND LAURA
HEALTH CONSULTANT AND
REPRESENTING WE THE PEOPLE
ADAMANTLY OPPOSED TO SCANDAL AND
I'M SHOCKED BY THE GUYS WHO
LANGUAGE ON HERE THANK YOU. NINE
ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M
SIDNEY STARTS FROM PARENT COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI
MY NAME IS SERENA LATCH I
REPRESENT JAMES HE BRADLEY FOR
U. S. SENATE BERMAN HE SHOULD BE
REMOVED FROM YOUR STATE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO I'M SUSAN BLACK
FROM SONOMA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. NINE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS GOING TO PASS
IT ON THE LEFT IN THE L. A. T.
P. FOUR EIGHTY SIXTY THREE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT ST PETER
DEMOCRATIC CLUB. AND RETIRED
TEACHER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE STOP IT STYLE L. THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JONATHAN MORTON UCLA ALONG
ORGANIZATION PROTECT US AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE- THANK YOU
. ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
KATHY WHITE MEN I'M FROM WINTER
CALIFORNIA AND WITH THE STATE
ARTS ACADEMY GROUP AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. NINE ONE FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES I'M THE CALL YOUNG CHAPTER
CARE PLASTER COUNTY MONSTER
LIBERTY I REPRESENT OVER TWO
THOUSAND FAMILIES AND PLASTER
COUNTY AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILL INVITED BECAUSE IT
VIOLATES HER FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE
ONE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE- CASHIER
WILLIAM PLASTER COUNTY RESIDENT
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES PUBLIC SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CLINTON OF THAT COMBI HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH COALITION
ADVOCACY OPPOSE UNLESS FURTHER
AMENDED THANK YOU. NINE ONE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS. THANKS-COUNTY CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND SHAME ON
YOU FOR USING THAT TYPE OF
LANGUAGE IN THIS FORM THANK YOU
. NINE ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
ANNA KATHLEEN OF THE CAMERON
FAMILY ON THE LAND OF THE
SENATORS COUNTY. AND A MEMBER OF
A VOICE FOR CHOI ADVOCACY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL YOU
SHOULD BE ASHAMED AND WE KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE DOING WE'RE COMING
FOR YOU. BOB GOT IT. NINE FIFTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS MERRY
CHRISTIANSEN AND THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY REGISTERED VOTERS MOTHER
AND GRANDMOTHER I'M APPALLED BY
THE LANGUAGE USED BY THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. ONE ONE
THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KERRY PLAN KIDS BY REDKNAPP
ORANGE COUNTY ANNEX STRONGLY
OCCURRED L. THANK YOU THANK YOU
. NINE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SONOMA
NAZARIAN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
SURVIVORS MEDICAL HARMS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. NINE ONE SIXTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS NICOLE PRODOTTO I AM
APPEARING I AM ALSO A SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT EDUCATOR AND I AM
STRONG OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE OF FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS CRYSTAL VINSON SINI
PLASTER COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
AMERICA AND WE OPPOSE COMMUNISM
THANK YOU. NINE ONE EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS DANIEL FROM
FRESNO AND I REPRESENT LIKE
GETTING THOUSANDS OF LIKES
LATINOS AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME FOR AB TWENTY NINETY
EIGHT OKAY WILL BRING BACK TO
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. ANY YES DOCTOR WEBER.
GOOD MORNING- SO THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY A DIRECT RESPONSE TO
THE GROWING AMOUNT OF
MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION- THAT WE SEE NOT
ONLY HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT JUST
ACROSS THE COUNTRY I'M DUE TO
COLD ED. AND YOU KNOW THIS WAS
ACTUALLY BROUGHT UP INITIALLY BY
THE FEDERAL FEDERATION OF STATE
AND MEDICAL BOARDS- BECAUSE THEY
SAW. A HUGE UPTICK IN THE NUMBER
OF COMPLAINTS THAT THEY GOT FROM
PATIENTS I'M ABOUT THE
PHYSICIANS THAT WERE LICENSED
UNDER THEM FOR DISTRIBUTING FALL
. LEADING INFORMATION AND WITH
HOLDING CERTAIN INFORMATION. AND
I ALSO WANT TO REMIND MY
COLLEAGUES THOSE THAT ARE HERE
AND THOSE THAT WILL HOPEFULLY BE
COMING. ON THAT AT THE END OF
LAST SESSION WE PASSED HR
SEVENTY FOUR. AND IN THAT WE
DECLARED HEALTH MISINFORMATION A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. AND WE
COMMITTED TO APPROPRIATELY
COMBATING. HEALTH MISINFORMATION
AND CURBING THE SPREAD OF FALSE
SAID THAT THREATEN THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF CALIFORNIANS. AND
THIS IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES. AS
A LICENSED PHYSICIAN WE POSSESS
A VERY HIGH DEGREE OF PUBLIC
TRUST. AND WE ALSO HAVE AN
ETHICAL AND PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO NO HARM AND
TO SHARE INFORMATION THAT IS
FACTUAL AND SCIENTIFICALLY
GROUNDED. PURPOSELY SPREADING
INACCURATE INFORMATION
CONTRADICTS THAT RESPONSIBILITY
ERODES PUBLIC TRUST AND PUTS
PATIENTS AT RISK. I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD. I REALLY WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR VERY VERY THOUGHTFUL AND
THOROUGH ANALYSIS AND IF YOU
HAVEN'T READ IT WHETHER YOU ARE
HERE IN THE ROOM OR WATCHING OR
LISTENING. PLEASE DO. PLEASE
READ IT. I WANT TO THANK MY
MEDICAL COLLEAGUES FOR BEING
HERE AND ALSO FOR TELLING YOU
KNOW THE IMPACTS OF DIFFERENT
DISINFORMATION ON HEALTH FROM
THE GROUND LEVEL. WITH THE
AMENDMENTS AND AGAIN IF YOU READ
IT YOU'LL YOU'LL KNOW WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT. IT CLEARLY
DEFINES WHAT MISINFORMATION IS.
WHAT DIFFERENT WHAT THIS
INFORMATION IS AND WHAT IT MEANS
TO DISSEMINATE. IT ALSO
SPECIFIES WHAT MUST BE
CONSIDERED PRIOR TO BRINGING
DISCIPLINARY ACTION. AND I
BELIEVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
MENTIONED IT BUT I'M JUST GOING
TO READ IT AGAIN. PRIOR TO
BRINGING A DISCIPLINARY ACTION
AGAINST A LICENSEE UNDER THIS
SECTION. THE BOARD SHALL
CONSIDER BOTH WHETHER THE
LICENSEE DEPARTED FROM THE APPLE
CALL STANDARD OF CARE AND
WHETHER THE MISINFORMATION OR
DISINFORMATION RESULTED IN HARM
TO A PATIENT. THIS ANALYSIS ALSO
ADDRESSES THE ISSUE OF FREE
SPEECH I GOT A LOT OF EMAILS
ABOUT THAT. THIS HAS BEEN
DEBATED AND DECIDED BOTH OF THE
NINTH CIRCUIT AND THE SUPREME
COURT. THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN FREE SPEECH AND
PROFESSIONAL CONTACT. AND STATES
MAY REGULATE PROFESSIONAL
CONDUCT EVEN THOUGH THAT CONTENT
TO MAKE INCIDENTLY INVOLVED
SPEECH. WE POSITIONS WE ARE
PEOPLE TO. WE HAVE OUR OWN LIVES
WE HAVE OUR INDIVIDUAL BELIEFS
AND WE CAN FREELY SPEAK THOSE
BELIEFS IN PUBLIC. BUT WHEN THAT
SPREADS INTO OUR PRACTICE WHICH
LEADS TO DIRECT HARM OF
PATIENTS. THAT IS NOT OKAY. SO I
MIGHT BELIEVE THAT HYPERTENSION
IS NOT A REAL MEDICAL CONDITION
. I MIGHT EVEN GO OUT AND SPEAK
ABOUT IT AT CONFERENCES. BUT IF
YOU COME TO ME AND YOU HAVE A
BLOOD PRESSURE OF TWO HUNDRED
OVER ONE FIFTY. AND I SAY TO YOU
YOU'RE FINE. NO WORK UP IS
NEEDED. YOU DON'T NEED ANY
MEDICATIONS GO HOME. I HAVE
GIVEN YOU MISINFORMATION MY
PROFESSIONAL CONDUCT IS NOW A
QUESTION AND I AM LIABLE FOR
MEDICAL MALPRACTICE. SO MANY
THANK THE AUTHOR AGAIN FOR THIS
BILL. BECAUSE IT NOT ONLY
PROTECTS OUR PUBLIC. TAX THE
TRUST THAT SOCIETY HAS PUT IN
THE MEDICAL PROFESSION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DR WEBER. ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SEEING ANY MISTER LOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. NO THAT'S I
APOLOGIZE THAT'S THAT'S NOT THE
PROCESS WE HAVE. PLEASE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES WANT TO REAFFIRM THE
DEEP APPRECIATION FOR THE STAFF
AND THE PUBLIC PROCESS WHAT WE
ARE WITNESSING HERE TODAY IS
DEMOCRACY IN ACTION PERRANCE
SIMPLE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
PHYSICALLY CANNOT EVEN BE HERE
TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC TESTIMONY WE HAVE
A PORTAL OPENED FOR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
COME HERE IN PERSON AND THEN
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT I RESPECT AND
APPRECIATE ALL THOSE WILLING TO
COME AND PROVIDE THEIR INPUT.
THIS IS THE STATE OF PROCESS AS
WE KNOW THAT THE THERE ARE THREE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT AND WITH
THIS IS THE LEGISLATIVE BODY THE
DELIBERATIVE BODY TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY. DIVIDE
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE VARIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS AND DEPARTMENTS
WHICH IS THAT OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD. THE BILL IN FRONT
OF US AGAIN FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO BEST BE AWARE. IS
VERY. DIRECT WHICH IS AGAIN
NUMBER ONE TO ENSURE THAT THERE
ARE THE KNOWN AND SUPPORTED
STANDARDS OF CARE AND
MAINTAINING THAT INTEGRITY I
HAVE THERE IS A DEPARTURE OF THE
STANDARD OF CARE. AS WELL AS IN
IT. HARM TO A PATIENT THAT DOES
QUALIFY. AS MISCONDUCT AND
SPECIFICALLY THE DISSEMINATION
IS DEFINED AS GROSS NEGLIGENCE
THE DEFINITION OF MISINFORMATION
IS MALICIOUS INTENT IT IS VERY
SPECIFIC VERY DIRECT. IMPORTANT
THAT WE HELP A LOT CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD TO HAVE THESE
DEFINITIONS IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM AND PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE LIVES THAT'S
WHAT HIS LEGISLATION IS ABOUT.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OUR
VOTE BY VOTE WHEN THE PROPER
TIME PROVIDES ITSELF THANK YOU
MR LOW IN LET ME BEGIN BY
THINKING THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO VOICE THEIR OPINIONS.
ON THIS BILL TO THE COMMITTEE
TODAY AND LET ME APOLOGIZE FOR
CUSSING EARLIER I SHOULD NOT
HAVE DONE THAT. FOR ANYONE WHO
DID NOT GET THE CHANCE TO SPEAK
TODAY. I ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUBMIT
A COMMENT THROUGH OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE WE RECEIVED MANY
COMMENTS BOTH FOR AND AGAINST
THIS BILL AND I WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE COMMENTS ARE INDEED
REYES. I'D NEXT LIKE THIS AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
IN FOR WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE ON WHAT I BELIEVE ARE
STRONG AMENDMENTS. THAT DOCTOR
WEBER LAID OUT AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL DIRECTLY ADDRESS CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED REGARDING
CONSTITUTIONALITY AND ADD MORE
SPECIFICS TO THE BILL'S INTENT.
WE ALL AGREE THAT THE MEDICAL
BOARD SHOULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ACT WHENEVER A PHYSICIAN
DEVIATES EGREGIOUSLY FROM THE
STANDARD OF CARE. AND THIS BILL
CONFIRMS THAT THERE IS NO
EXCEPTION IT FOR THE SPREAD OF
CODE NINETEEN MISINFORMATION
WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY ONCE
WE HAVE A QUORUM- AND ARE ABLE.
TO TAKE A VOTE. MISTER LOWE
THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THE HEARING.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO OUR
SECOND. AGENDA ITEM ON TODAY'S
HEARING THANK YOU. THEY MAKE
THEIR SECOND AGENDA ITEMS ON
CONSENT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
OUR THIRD AGENDA ITEM- YEP READY
WHEN YOUR DOCTOR WEBER. THIS
WILL BE A BE SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX.
PLEASE OUR DRIVER GOOD MORNING
SHARON MEMBERS. I WANT TO BEGIN
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX THE
PATIENT PROTECTION ACT A BILL TO
MAINTAIN CONFIDENCE IN THE
MEDICAL PROFESSION BY ENSURING
PHYSICIANS CONVICTED OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT AUTOMATICALLY HAVE
THEIR LICENSE REVOKED AND
CANNOT. ACQUIRE OR HAVE IT
REINSTATED IF THE SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT WAS DONE TOWARDS ONE
OF THEIR PATIENTS. IN DECEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES REPORTED INSTANCES
WHERE PHYSICIANS COMMITTED ACTS
OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT AGAINST
THEIR PATIENTS. IN ALL THE
REPORTED INSTANCES THE PHYSICIAN
EITHER HAD THEIR LICENSE REVOKED
OR THE POSITION SURRENDER THEIR
LIFE. THESE POSITION
SUBSEQUENTLY PETITIONED THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA FOR
LICENSOR REINSTATEMENT AND
ACCORDING TO THE REPORT THE
MEDICAL BOARD REINSTATED
REINSTATED TEN. OF THE SEVENTEEN
OR ABOUT 60% OF THOSE
PETITIONING PHYSICIANS. THANK
GOD IT TO DOCTORS WHO ABUSED
TEENAGE GIRLS AND ONE WHO BEAT
TWO FEMALE PATIENTS WHEN THEY
REPORTED HIM FOR SEXUALLY
EXPLOITING THEM. CURRENTLY A
PERSON MAY PETITION THE MEDICAL
BOARD FOR REINSTATEMENT AFTER
THREE YEARS AFTER HAVING THEIR
LICENSE REVOKED OR SURRENDERED
FOR UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT. THE
MEDICAL BOARD MAY SPECIFY IN
ORDER THAT A PETITION FOR
REINSTATEMENT MAY BE FILED AFTER
TWO YEARS. AS WE KNOW THE
MEDICAL BOARD IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE LICENSURE REGULATION AND
DISCIPLINE OF PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS. THIS THING LAW
REQUIRES THAT THE BOARD DENY A
PHYSICIAN'S AND SURGEON'S
CERTIFICATE TO ANYONE WHO IS
REQUIRED TO REGISTER AS A SEX
OFFENDER AN EXISTING LAW MAKES
AN APPLICANT IN ELIGIBLE TO
REAPPLY FOR THAT CERTIFICATE FOR
A MINIMUM OF THREE YEARS THE
EFFECTIVE EIGHT. OR NINE OUT OF
THEIR APPLICATION. APPLICANTS
FREQUENTLY REAPPLY AFTER THE
THREE YEAR WAITING PERIOD AND
THE BOARD FREQUENTLY REINSTATES
THOSE APPLICANTS CERTIFICATES.
SO THIS BILL MAKES IT CLEAR THAT
PHYSICIANS TO COMMIT THIS
EGREGIOUS CONDUCT TURNING THEIR
PATIENTS INTO THEIR PREY SHOULD
NOT PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
REMOVE THE DISCRETION THAT THEY
WOULD EVER PRACTICE IN THE STATE
AGAIN. AB SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX IS
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORTED BY AN ORGANIZATION
SUCH AS THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS THE CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBSTETRICIAN
GYNECOLOGISTS DISTRICT NINE
CALIFORNIA. ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRIST. CONSUMER
PROTECTION POLICY CENTER. CITY
OF SAN DIEGO SCHOOL OF LAW. TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY SIX I HAVE DR TANYA
SPIRIT TELLS. FELLOW OBGYN AND
SPEAKING THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND KAREN LARD WHO
IS ACTUALLY A PATIENT SURVIVOR
AND CALLING ON THE PHONE GREAT
THANK YOU DR WEBBER- AND DOCTORS
PROTEST IF YOU LIKE TO BE IN.
ZARQAWI TO. I WOULD MIND THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIRPERSON
BERMAN AND MEMBERS ALL RE
INTRODUCE MYSELF MY NAME IS DR
TANYA SPIRITUS I'M A BOARD
CERTIFIED OBSTETRICIAN
GYNECOLOGIST PRACTICING IN
REDWOOD CITY CALIFORNIA I AM
ALSO THE SPEAKER THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION HOUSE OF
DELEGATES AND A MEMBER OF CMA'S
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON
CMA'S BEHALF AS SPONSORS OF AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX. THE INTENT
OF THIS BILL IS SIMPLE IF YOU
ARE A PHYSICIAN PRACTICING IN
CALIFORNIA OR ELSEWHERE AND YOU
ARE CONVICTED OF A CRIME WHICH
REQUIRES REGISTRATION AS A SEX
OFFENDER PURSUANT TO PENAL CODE
TO NINETY OR COMMITTED AN
OFFENCE WHICH WOULD HAVE BEEN
PUNISHABLE IN CALIFORNIA YOU
WILL LOSE YOUR PRIVILEGE TO
PRACTICE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HAVE YOUR
APPLICATION DENIED TO PRACTICE
IN THE STATE THE BILL LANGUAGE
WAS NARROWLY TAILORED. LOTS OF
TO REPORTING IN THE LOS ANGELES
TIMES HIGHLIGHTING INSTANCES OF
PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS
COMMITTING THESE HORRENDOUS ACTS
WITH THE PATIENT OR CLIENT. THE
REPORTING WAS APPALLING ALL OF
US. IN INSTANCES LIKE THESE
SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN. AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY SIX IS AN ATTEMPT TO
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT STATUTORY
AUTHORITY. TO PROTECT PATIENTS
AND THE PUBLIC. SURE TRUST IN
THE PROFESSION IS MAINTAINED
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
COMMONSENSE MEASURE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
KEREN LINED UP BY PHONE EIGHTEEN
THE OPERATOR IF YOU CAN IDENTIFY
KAREN'S LINED AND- OPEN SO SHE
CAN TESTIFY. HER LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME
TESTIFIED THIS MORNING AS A
PATIENT BUT SURVIVED A SEXUAL
ASSAULT DURING MY CANCER
TREATMENT THE IMPORTANT. HELP
FOR THE FUTURE OF SO MANY PEOPLE
OUT THERE THAT TRUST. MOTIONS TO
ALWAYS. PROTECT THEM HAVE THEIR
WELL BEING. ANOTHER TO HURT THE
MALICIOUSLY LIKE I WITH HER. IT
IS A VERY DIFFICULT TIME AND THE
CUSTOMER AND PROSPECT TWO YEARS
LATER FOR ME. AND I'M NEVER
GOING TO BE OKAY I SURVIVED
CANCER ONLY. MY BURKE. SUMMIT
FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WELCOME THE COURTS
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR TESTIFYING THIS MORNING
WE'RE NOT GONNA MOVE TO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE WE HAVE JANICE BELLUCCI
FROM THE ALLIANCE FOR
CONSTITUTIONAL SEX OFFENSE LAWS
BY PHONE OPERATOR IF YOU CAN
IDENTIFY MS BLUE CHEESE LINE.
THAT BE GREAT. HI LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN BERMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SO THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE IN THE ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX I WANT TO
STATE CLEARLY THAT WE AGREE WITH
THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL WHICH IS
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC. BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL IS TOO
BROAD AND IN FACT INCLUDES-
CATEGORICAL EXCLUSION OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO DO NOT POSE A
CURRENT DANGER TO THE PUBLIC.
THE BILL IN FACT HAS UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES INCLUDING THAT IT
WOULD ADD TO THE SHORTAGE OF
PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS WHICH IS
PROJECTED AT THIS POINT THE ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE THOUSAND
BY THE YEAR TWENTY THIRTY THREE.
L. PREVENT FOLKS WHO ARE
OTHERWISE QUALIFIED FROM
LICENSURE. SO THE FOR THE WHO
DON'T ALREADY KNOW THERE ARE
ABOUT A HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE ON SEX GENDER REGISTRY
TODAY IN CALIFORNIA. AND MANY OF
THESE PEOPLE WERE CONVICTED OF A
SEX OFFENSE WHEN THEY WERE
TEENAGERS IN FACT IT'S A FASTEST
GROWING PART OF OUR REGISTRY.
AND SO WE HAVE FOR EXAMPLE A
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD GIRL WHO
CHECKED ME IN SOUTHEAST AND FOR
THOSE WHO SOUTHEAST IMPACT YOU-
PEOPLE IN HER HIGH SCHOOL. AND
SHE WAS CONVICTED OF- PRODUCING
AND DISTRIBUTING CHILD ****
AGAIN THESE WERE NEW SELFIE. SO
BACK TO THE PRIMARY MESSAGE HERE
WE AGREE WITH THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL WHICH IS TO PROTECT PUBLIC
INCLUDING PATIENTS. THAT WE
DISAGREE WITH THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE AND BELIEVE. THAT IT IS
TOO BROAD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MUCH NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TWO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. ARE EITHER
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THE
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL JUST A
REMINDER. ORGANISE YOUR WAY IF
ANY AND SUPPORT FOR OPPOSITE
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL WILL
START WITH FOLKS HERE IN THE
HEARING TODAY. IS GOOD- GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ERIN
BONE WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA THE BOARD HAS A
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION ON
THE BILL- WE HAVE SOME REQUESTED
AMENDMENTS TO. WE BELIEVE
INTENDED TO STRENGTHEN THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL AND
FURTHER ENHANCE CONSUMER
PROTECTION WE APPRECIATE DR
WEBER'S ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE.
THE BOARD WILL BE DISCUSSING ITS
RECENT MET THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
AND MEMBERS TAKEN TODAY- SEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
RESTAURANTS ARE PERHAPS THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
INSTITUTE NINE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. HI DOCTOR LAWRENCE TRONG
SUMMER THIS CO OP HAS PRESIDENT
SERVICES GO MEDICAL SOCIETY AND
A PAST SERVICES GO COUNTY
COMMISSIONER FOR THE HEALTH
AUTHORITY FROM THE SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
DR JERRY ABRAHAM FAMILY
PHYSICIAN FROM LOS ANGELES
PRESIDENT ELECT OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
TRUSTEE THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU TO WHOEVER THANK YOU. DR ED
A. APPLE MERCHANTS THE MEDICINE
AT UCLA SPEAKING IN FRONT
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
TO WHOEVER. THANK YOU. MIKE
CONNERY FROM SACRAMENTO AN
INTERNIST AND A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES OF CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. TIM MURPHY
PSYCHIATRIST AND FORMER
CALIFORNIA PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION. HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION PSYCHIATRIST
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK. THANK YOU. TO
MADDEN REPS IN THE CALIFORNIA
RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM
TODAY IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. SEEING NONE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES THIS
IS FOR A. B. SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX.
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER THREE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
NINE TWO SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
ROCK AMERICANS ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTERS FOR PUBLIC INTEREST LAW
THE CONSUMER PROTECTION POLICY
CENTER AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MINE TOO SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS MERION
HOLLINGSWORTH FROM THE PATIENT'S
SITUATION THE PATIENT PATIENT
SAFETY ACTION NETWORK SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MY NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU USE THE NON
MEDICINE AND THE SIR PROSECUTION
SO I OPPOSE THANK YOU. TWENTY
TWO FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS ANNE
MARIE SORENSEN FULL CHARGE
BOOKKEEPER IN THE SIERRA NEVADA
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU THINK
YOU. WE HAVE NO MORE COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE FOR AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
BRING BACK THE COLLEAGUES FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS STARTING
ON MY RIGHT LOOKING TO MY LEFT
NOT SEEING ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS DR WEBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE YES THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THAT PATIENT DOCTOR RELATIONSHIP
IS BASED ON TRUST AND PATIENCE
WITH THIS RELATIONSHIP ARE IN
PARTICULAR VULNERABLE SITUATION
AS WE HEARD FROM- ONE OF OUR OUR
WITNESSES WHEN I MAKE IT VERY
CLEAR THAT THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY GOES AFTER THOSE
PHYSICIANS WHO HAVE VIOLATED
THAT TRUST BY PERFORMING- SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT. WITH THEIR PATIENTS
. NO PHYSICIAN WHO HAS ENGAGED
IN SEXUAL MISCONDUCT WITH THEIR
PATIENT AND REGISTERED AS A SEX
OFFENDER SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
RETURN TO PRACTICE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR- THANK
YOU. WEBER AND THANK YOU FOR
ACTING SWIFTLY THE INTRODUCED
THIS BILL IN RESPONSE TO
DISTURBING NEWS. REPORTS
REGARDING THE MEDICAL BOARD AND
I CERTAINLY AGREE THAT DOCTORS
WHO COMMIT HORRIFIC ABUSE
AGAINST THEIR PATIENTS SHOULD
NOT BE ALLOWED TO HAVE THEIR
LICENSE BACK- SO I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL- WITH SOME OF
THE MOMENTS OR WITH THE
AMENDMENTS TODAY. AND WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM WHICH WERE A
COUPLE OF MEMBERS AND MEMBER
STATUS WHO ARE WATCHING ON TV
JUST A COUPLE MEMBERS AWAY FROM
A QUORUM CENTER DOWN HERE FOR A
MINUTE WE'LL GET A QUORUM WE CAN
START VOTE ON BILLS. BUT UNTIL
THAT TIME WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON-
TWO ADDITIONAL PRESENTERS THANK
YOU DOCTOR WEBER THANK YOU
THANKS. SO WE HAVE LET ME MAKE
SURE I GET THIS. IN THE RIGHT
ORDER I BELIEVE AS A MEMBER
KALRA IS UP NEXT. WITH ITEM
NUMBER FIVE ON THE AGENDA AB.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR THE OPTION PRESENT
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE. FOUR
YEARS AGO AB TWENTY FIFTEEN WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW ALLOWED
VETERINARIANS DISCUSS THE USE OF
CANNABIS WITHOUT FEAR OF LOSING
THEIR STATE LICENSE AND CANNABIS
FOR THERAPEUTIC THE PEDIC ANIMAL
USE ACCESSIBLE TO CONSUMERS TO
REGULATED DISPENSARIES. HOWEVER
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN DID NOT
EXPRESSLY ALLOW VETERINARIANS TO
RECOMMEND CANNABIS USE. SAYS
THEN THERE'S BEEN MOUNTING
EVIDENCE SUPPORTING THE
THERAPEUTIC EFFECTS OF CANNABIS
USE IN ANIMALS IN FACT MANY PET
OWNERS ARE ALREADY AWARE THESE
FINDINGS ARE GIVING THEIR
ANIMALS. CANNABIS PRODUCTS
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE THE LACK
OF AUTHORITY IN EXISTING LAW THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THESE PET
OWNERS ARE DOING SO WITHOUT ANY
RECOMMENDATION OR GUIDANCE. FROM
A VETERINARIAN. IT'S TIME TO
ALLOW VETERINARIANS RECOMMEND
SAFE REGULATED THERAPEUTIC
CANNABIS PRODUCTS FOR THEIR
ANIMAL PATIENTS. IF WE DO NOT
PET OWNERS WILL HAVE NO CHOICE
BUT TO TURN TO UNSAFE PET
CANNABIS PRACTICES. LIKE THE
GIVEN THEIR ANIMALS CANNABIS
PRODUCTS DESIGNED FOR HUMANS OR
LYING RELYING UPON UNREGULATED
UNDERGROUND MARKET. AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE WOULD REQUIRE THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD TO
ADOPT GUIDELINES FOR
VETERINARIANS TO FOLLOW WHEN
THEY RECOMMEND THE USE OF
CANNABIS DERIVED THERAPEUTIC
PRODUCTS ON AN ANIMAL. WITHIN
THE VETERINARIAN CLIENT PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP. SIMILAR A SIMILAR
GUIDELINES FOR PHYSICIANS
RECOMMENDING CANNABIS ARE
DEVELOPED BY THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA. TO ENSURE THAT
CANADA'S PRODUCTS INTENDED FOR
ANIMAL USE ARE AVAILABLE TO
CONSUMERS ON THE REGULATED
MARKET. AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
ADDS THEM TO THE EXISTING
DEFINITION OF CANNABIS. PRODUCTS
UNDER MAO CARISSA AND REQUIRES
THEM TO A DEAR TO CANNABIS
REGULATIONS AND RELEVANT
MANUFACTURING PACKAGING LABELING
STANDARDS. AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE STRIKES A REASONABLE
BALANCE BETWEEN THE EXISTING
COMPREHENSIVE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK FOR CANNABIS AND THE
ABILITY FOR VETERINARY
PROFESSIONALS PROVIDE CLEAR
RECOMMENDATIONS AND GUIDANCE TO
THEIR CLIENTS. THIS BROWN'S WILL
ENSURE TAT PETS CAN SAFELY
BENEFIT FROM THE MANY
THERAPEUTIC USES OF CANNABIS.
THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION BUSINESS GROUPS OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND THE BEST FRIENDS
ANIMAL SOCIETY WHEN THE
NATION'S. LEADING ANIMAL WELFARE
AND RESCUE ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS. WITH ME TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY SUPPORT IS
ELIZABETH ORECK NATIONAL MANAGER
INITIALLY IS A BEST. WITH THE
BEST FRIENDS ANIMAL SOCIETY AND
PAMELA LOPEZ. ON BEHALF OF THE
PET CANNABIS COALITION. THANK
YOU GREAT THANK YOU MISTER KALRA
DID ANY SPECIFIC ORDER FOR THE
PLEASE GO RIGHT AHEAD SURE- GOOD
MORNING MR BERMAN WHEN I'M
CANNABIS DISPENSARIES OPENED
JANUARY ONE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
LICENSED AND LEGAL PET CANNABIS
PRODUCTS WERE WIDELY AVAILABLE.
UNFORTUNATELY REGULATORY
AGENCIES REALIZED MID YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY THAT THEY DID NOT
HAVE THE REGULATORY AUTHORITY
FOR THESE PRODUCTS SPECIFICALLY
AND THEY WERE PULLED FROM THE
MARKET. NOW YOU CAN IMAGINE IF
YOU LOVE YOUR DOG OR YOU LOVE
YOUR CAT AND- THE LIFESAVING
TREATMENT FOR LEPROSY FOR THAT
MORE ARTHRITIS OR A WHOLE RANGE
OF AILMENTS FOR WHICH CANNABIS
IS EFFECTIVE. YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO STOP TAKING CARE OF THEM
SIMPLY BECAUSE THESE THERAPIES
WHICH YOU KNOW TO BE EFFECTIVE
HAVE BEEN TAKEN OFF OF THE
MARKET. UNFORTUNATELY WHILE THE
RESEARCH WHICH WE'VE SUBMITTED
TO COMMITTEE SHOWS THAT CANNABIS
IS A SAFE THERAPY FOR PAT'S-
SOMETIMES HUMAN PRODUCTS ARE NOT
A SAFE THERAPY FOR PETS AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE SEEN AN
UPTICK. IN ANECDOTAL REPORTS
FROM VETERINARY A VERY LOVING
PET PARENTS WERE ACCIDENTALLY
MADE THEIR PAT ILL WITH HUMAN
CANNABIS THIS BILL AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA MENTIONED WILL
ALLOW PET PARENTS TO DO THE
BEHAVIORS WHICH COME NATURALLY.
AND EMPOWER THEM TO DO THOSE
BEHAVIORS WHICH IS TO TAKE GOOD
CARE OF THEIR PETS ONE BY HAVING
ACCESS TO CLEAR RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM VETERINARY MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS. AND TO BY BEING
EASILY ABLE TO FIND CLEARLY UP
PRODUCTS THAT ARE CLEARLY
LABELED WITH CLEAR INSTRUCTIONS
ON DOSING AND SO FORTH FOR THE
PATS I THIS IS A BILL THAT'S
TIME HAS COME TWO YEARS IS TOO
LONG FOR PEOPLE. TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THESE PRODUCTS WITH CLEAR
INSTRUCTION AFTER THEY WERE ON
THE- THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE
ELIZABETH ORIC- ON THE PHONE
OPERATOR IF YOU CAN FIND
ELIZABETH. LINE AND OPEN IT UP A
GREAT. HER LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TERRY
BERMAN AND HONORABLE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
ORECK AND I AM THE NATIONAL
MANAGER OF CAMPAIGNS AND
INITIATIVES FOR BEST FRIENDS
ANIMAL SOCIETY AND NATIONAL
ANIMAL WELFARE AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF OUR THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS SUPPORT. FOR
NURSING STAFF IN FULL SUPPORT AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE IN TWENTY
TWENTY HALF A MILLION DOGS AND
CATS ENTERED CALIFORNIA SHELTERS
AND MORE THAN THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND WERE KILLED SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T HAVE A SAFE
PLACE TO CALL HOME. VETERANS IS
COMMITTED TO GETTING THAT NUMBER
TO ZERO SO THAT EVERY PETTING
CALIFORNIA SHELTERS IS ABLE TO
FIND A HOME AND ONE OF THE WAYS
TO ACHIEVE THOSE POSITIVE
OUTCOMES IS TO ENSURE THAT PETS
HAVE ACCESS TO ANY AND ALL
THERAPIES THAT MIGHT INCREASE
THEIR CHANCES OF GETTING
ADOPTED. PETS SEND UP IN
SHELTERS BRIONY REASONS OFTEN
IT'S BECAUSE THEY'RE FACING
PHYSICAL BEHAVIORAL OR
PSYCHOLOGICAL CHALLENGES THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN FULLY ADDRESSED AND
SOMETIMES THOSE DOWN TO THE
KIRBY THEY'VE LANDED IN A
SHELTER FOR SOME PATHS
THERAPEUTIC CANNABIS IS AN
APPROPRIATE TOOL TO HELP THEM
GET WELL AND HAVE THEIR BEST
CHANCE AT ADOPTION AS THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER SAID RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT CANNABIS MAY BE AN
APPROPRIATE THERAPY FOR
ILLNESSES AS PROFOUND AS APPLE
UPSEE. OR CONDITIONS AS COMMON
AS ARTHRITIS PAIN ALTHOUGH
CANNABIS IS ACCESSIBLE IN
CALIFORNIA GUIDANCE ON ISSUES IS
CURRENTLY NOT. X. TO ALLOW THAT
. TO DISCUSS THEIR CANNABIS WITH
PAT PARENTS AND REST. WHO FEAR
OF LEGAL REPERCUSSIONS AND
PROVIDE ACCESS TO LICENSED AND
LEGAL PRODUCTS WITH CLEAR LABELS
AND INSTRUCTIONS FOR USE IN
ANIMALS. THIS IS WHAT EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE WILL DO AND
THIS IS WHY WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND WE URGE
YOUR AYE BUT TODAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND WE
I DON'T HAVE ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION NEXT
WILL MOVE O ANY. OUT ON-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MAY CATCH A GLIMPSE OF K. STREET
CONSULTING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA NORMAL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND WE GOT
SOME FOLKS COMING IN. MAYBE FOR
THIS MAYBE FOR SOMETHING ELSE OR
THIS NOT FOR THIS NOT FOR THIS
GUY JUST GETTING- ANY IS ALSO
ONE OF THE PHONE LINES ANY
WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES. I
JUST A REMINDER YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH OF ANY
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
THANKS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. MINE TOO NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TO NINETY YOU MAY BE
ON YOUR HEAD YES WE CAN AREA
HELLO. OKAY IN OUR OPPOSITION OF
TWENTY NINETEEN. AND TWENTY
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU
A LONG LINE THANK YOU YEAH WE
HAD OR HEARD THAT BILL EARLIER
BUT WILL- IF YOU WANNA GIVE US
YOUR NAME AND WILL KNOW YOUR
OPPOSITION. ARE YOU DON'T HAVE
TO GIVE US YOUR NAME IF YOU
DON'T WANT TO. THEN WE MOVED ON
I'M SORRY NO WE HAVE NO DOUBT
ABOUT THAT NO PROBLEM THANK YOU
NINETY. NINETEEN NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
CHRISTINA TO CARO REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONE TWO
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBERS THIS IS EDWIN MORE
BALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THOUGHT THE COMING
INTO THEIR OWN BILL BUT- IF YOU
CAN TAKE MY NAME DOWN COULD BE A
LOT TWENTY NINE ZERO EIGHT
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS AVAILABLE
FROM A UNION REPRESENTATIVE OR
LECTURES AND BOOKS SIX SEVENTEEN
WEBSITE NINE HUNDRED MEMBERS.
AND WE BOTH KNOW ON. TWENTY
NINETY EIGHT. OKAY AND OUR
MARKET PLEASE BIGELOW ARCHER
ABOUT PETER LISTENING PLEASE
THANK YOU THANK YOU DULY NOTED-
AND THANK YOU FOR WAITING IN-
ANY ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
REGARDS TO A BE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
AT THIS TIME I DO NOT HAVE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS IN CURING ABOUT
EIGHTY DOLLARS EIGHTY FIVE.
QUESTIONS THANK YOU OPERATOR AND
QUESTIONS COMMENTS THERE ARE NO
MUGS ARE GONNA START MY LEFT
THIS TIME. NOPE GOING ALL RIGHT
NOPE SUMMARY LIKE TO CLOSE
SPECIALLY ASTRONAUT ADD TO THE
MY FAVORITE CLOTHES THING HERE
TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE AS A
MEMBER KALRA IT IS IMPORTANT
THE- IT IS IMPORTANT TO ENSURE
ALL CALIFORNIA PET PATIENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO SAFE. REGULATED AND
TESTED CANNABIS ALWAYS
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
REGEDIT AND WE ARE I THINK ONE
ONE IT MEMBER AWAY FROM A QUORUM
JUST ONE THAT'S ALL WE NEED- BUT
WHEN WE GET ONE WILL VOTE ON THE
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO
MOVE ON I'VE GOT THIS NUMBER IN
HIS AREA AND HIDING IN THE
CORNER WITH ITEM NUMBER SIX. AB. IN NINETEEN OH ONE.
THANK YOU FOR THE COMPLIMENT I
DIDN'T THINK MY SIZE ALLOWED ME
TO BE HOLDING YOU YOU BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU. I'M
SAYING NOTHING NOTHING. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND- AND
COLLEAGUES FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT THIS LEGISLATION AND
FOR ALL OF THE SUPPORT YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF IS ALSO OFFERED
OF AB NINETEEN OH ONE REQUIRES A
DOG TRAINER TO DISCLOSE BASIC
INFORMATION TO DOG OWNERS
PURCHASING THEIR SERVICES TO
BETTER INFORM THE DOG OWNERS
DECISIONS. THE REQUIRED
INFORMATION TO BE DISCLOSED
INCLUDES THE DOCTOR'S NAME AND
ADDRESS TRAINING TECHNIQUES AND
PHILOSOPHY TRAINING PLAN ANY
CIVIL JUDGMENTS RELATED TO THE
DOG TRAINER SERVICES AND WHETHER
OR NOT THEY ARE CERTIFIED OR
LICENSED AS OUR WITNESSES WILL
TESTIFY. TOO MANY OWNERS HAVE
BEEN DOG OWNERS HAVE BEEN
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY TRAINERS
WHO WITHHOLD THEIR
QUALIFICATIONS AND TRAINING
TECHNIQUES WE HAVE LISTENED TO A
LOT OF FEEDBACK FROM GROUPS
ABOUT THIS BILL. THROUGH THESE
CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE AMENDED
THIS BILL SIGNIFICANTLY BY
CUTTING THE PERIPHERY AND
FOCUSING ON THE CORE INTENT
INCREASING DISCLOSURE. IN THE
TRANSACTION BETWEEN DOG OWNERS
AND THEIR TRAINERS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION-
I BELIEVE I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
THANK YOU US HONORING HIS AREA
THEN ES I BELIEVE YOU ARE JANE
CRESSWELL AND LORNE. TESTIFYING
BY PHONE OPERATOR IF YOU CAN
IDENTIFY THE START WITH JANE
CRESSWELL BECAUSE SHE'S FOR SOME
A SHEET. TWO TO TESTIFY AGAIN
EVERYBODY GET TWO MINUTES- FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY PER WITNESS. WELL
I AM APEC COUNTER IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN- I HIRED A
DOG TRAINER WHO ALSO- WITH
PORTING ONE OF MY DOGS BUT BOTH
DOG HAPPENED TO BE THERE AT THE
TIME WHEN I WAS GOING ON
VACATION- DOG ENDED UP KILLING.
MY ONE DOG THAT RECORDED WITH
HER AT NIGHT OTHER DOG WAS
SEVERELY NAMES. AND HAD MANY
MANY MEDICAL ISSUES- I DO
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
PROTECTS THE PAST BUT IT ALSO
PROTECTS THE- OWNER THAT THE
PET. NO HISTORY AND INFORMATION
OF THE DOG TRAINER AND IN MY
CASE I DIDN'T HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE THERE WASN'T
A BILL LIKE THAT- I JUST WENT
BASED ON HER WEBSITE WHICH SAID
THAT SHE WAS THE NUMBER ONE DOG
TRAINER IN MY AREA. AND I MET
THE PERSON AND SHE SEEMS LIKE
SHE YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
TRAIN A DOG. SO ITRUSTED HER
AND I INSTRUCTED MY DOG WITH HER
AND ONE WAS KILLED BY HER DOG
AND SHE WAS VERY DISHONEST
ABOUT. HER QUALIFICATIONS AND
HISTORY ONCE I DID GET A BIT
MORE INTO HER BACKGROUND I FOUND
OUT THAT YOU KNOW SHE SHE
MISREPRESENTED HERSELF SO I DO
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE I
THINK. IT'S IT'LL BE IN WRITING
AND I THINK IT'LL PROTECT A PET
OWNERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
AS IT BEFORE WE GO TO MS MYERS
WE HAVE A QUORUM I WANT TO
CAPTURE THIS MOMENT AND- GAVIN
BE NOTED IN THE RECORD. SO MR
SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. BERMAN HERE FOR
ARAMBULA MMHM BONTA CHEN
CUNNINGHAM DALY FONG GIPSON
GRAYSON R. ONE. ME MCCARTY
MEDINA MULLIN CHAIN WARD WEBER.
GREAT WE HAVE A QUORUM SORRY
ABOUT THAT MS MYERS- OPERATOR
PLEASE IDENTIFY MS MYERS LINE
AND OPENED IT SO SHE CAN TESTIFY
. HER MIND IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES HELLO MY NAME IS
LAUREN MYERS AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN NO ONE MY FAMILY
EXPERIENCED TERRIBLE HEARTBREAK
AT THE HANDS OF OUR DOG TRAINER
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS AND HAD
THERE BEEN CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS
WE NEVER WOULD HAVE TRAVELED
DOWN THIS ROAD MY HUSBAND AND I
ARE BOTH DISABLED VETERANS AND
OUR OLDEST CHILD IS AUTISTIC WE
REALLY NEEDED HELP AND TRAINING
ARE DURABLE BUT HIGHLY ENERGETIC
GERMAN SHEPHERD FOR. WE HOPE
STORE COULD BE TRAINED TO BE A
SERVICE ANIMAL FOR OUR DAUGHTER
AND SHE HAD FORGED A VERY STRONG
BOND WITH HIM HE CAME FROM A
LINE OF EXTREMELY WELL TRAINED
DOG. UNFORTUNATELY WE WOULD HAND
OVER OUR BELOVED PUPPY ON
OCTOBER EIGHTEENTH TWENTY
NINETEEN. NOT KNOWING WE WOULD
NEVER SEE HIM AGAIN. WE AGREED
UPON AND PAID FOR A MONTH A
BOARDING AND TRAINING AND
THROUGH THE COURSE OF THAT TIME.
THE TRAINERS COMMUNICATION
SLOWLY DECREASED AND AFTER THE
FIRST MONTH HE TOLD US HE NEEDED
MORE TIME. A MONTH LATER HE TOLD
US HE HAD TAKEN OUR DOG OUT OF
STATE WHILE HE WAS TRAINING
OTHER DOC. AS WE CONTINUE TO
PRESS THEM FOR INFORMATION IN
ASKING FOR DOOR TO BE RETURNED
BECAUSE HE FINALLY REFUSED TO
SEND PICTURES OR UPDATE THE BILL
ARE. WE HAD NO IDEA WHERE TO
FIND THEM. WE FINALLY GOT THE
POLICE INVOLVED IN IT WAS THEN
WE DISCOVERED THAT HE NO LONGER
HAD DOOR AND REFUSED TO SAY
WHERE HE BOUGHT. THIS IS THE
START OF AN AWFUL EMOTIONAL
ROLLER COASTER TO NAVIGATE WITH
MY CHILDREN AS THEY STILL HOPE
TO THIS DAY. THAT THE TRAINER
WILL TELL US WHAT HAPPENED TO
FULLER. I DO NOT WISH ANY FAMILY
TO GO THROUGH THIS HORRIBLE
EXPERIENCE. SO MY HOPE IS THAT
WE CAN HELP PUT AN END TO THESE
NOW INTENDED AND MALICIOUS DOG
TRAINERS TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
FAMILIES AND THEIR BELOVED PAT.
I BELIEVE THAT HAD THE
REQUIREMENTS BABY NINETEEN NO
ONE DID IN PLACE WHEN I WAS
FIRST CONSIDERING A DOG TRAINER.
WE NEVER WOULD HAVE WORKED WITH
HIM. I HOPE THAT WOULD INCREASE
REQUIREMENTS FAMILIES WHO NEED
HELP IN TRAINING THEIR DOGS WILL
BE ABLE TO FIND RELIABLE AND
TRUSTWORTHY PROVIDERS. WHO
RETURN THEIR PET HAPPY. HEALTHY
AND SAFE WE TRAINED. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
CONSIDERATION IN THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
BOTH FOR TESTIFYING SO WE'RE
GONNA OPEN UP TO ANY ADDITIONAL-
I SHOULD SAY I DON'T SEE ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
I WILL OPEN IT UP TO. WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. IF ANYBODY
WOULD WISH TO TESTIFY AS ADD ON-
FOR HIS BILL DOES LOOK LIKE WE
HAVE ANY- SO LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES OPERATED WE HAVE
ANYBODY. ON THE PHONE IS WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETEEN OH ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN. YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
<c.red>N SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AB</c>
NINETEEN OH ONE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. OF AB NINETEEN OH
ONE. YOU MAY RESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. NINE THREE TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NICOLAS
TACKETT REPRESENTING SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NINE THREE OH NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS BILL GAINES OF
ACTUALLY HOPING TO PROVIDE LEAD
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY ON THIS MAY
I GO AHEAD AND DO SO. SURE YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I'M PROBABLY SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE BLACK BRANT
GROUP THE CALIFORNIA HOUSE GOOD
FOR CONSERVATION CAL OR WETLAND
AND WATERFOWL COUNCIL CALIFORNIA
HIKING CLUB THE CONGRESSIONAL
SPORTSMEN'S FOUNDATION THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WILDLIFE FEDERATION
AND THE TULARE BASED WEAPONS
ASSOCIATION ON THIS BILL. AGAIN
WE APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
CALLED OUT THE BILL ANALYSIS AND
ARE VERY GRATEFUL TO THE JOB
FIRST WILLINGNESS TO ACCEPT
THOSE AMENDMENTS INTO THE BILL
HOWEVER WE MUST REMAIN OPPOSED
TO THE LAST AMENDED TO ADDRESS
ONE REMAINING SERIOUS CONCERN.
AS SUPPOSED TO BE AMENDED
SECTION ONE TWO TWO THREE NINE
FIVE POINT TWO EIGHT TWO WOULD
REQUIRE THAT DOG TRAINER PROVIDE
PURCHASERS WITH A WRITTEN
DISCOSURE STATING WHETHER THE
TRAINER'S LICENSE OR CERTIFIED
BY ANY ANIMAL TRAINING
ORGANIZATION. ALRIGHT WELL
INTENDED WE BELIEVE THAT OUR
SUPPOSED THIS LANGUAGE WOULD
ONLY CREATE CONFUSION FOR BOTH
PRODUCERS AND TRAINERS DOCTORS
ARE NOT REQUIRED TO BE LICENSED
IN CALIFORNIA AND WHILE THERE
ARE CERTIFICATIONS FOR SOME
TYPES OF TRAINING THERE ARE NOT
FOR OTHERS INCLUDING SPORTING
DOG TRADING. TWO DRESSES ONE
REMAINING CONCERN AND TIM FLOYD
CONFUSION AT THE NOT CREATE
UNNECESSARY PROBLEMS IN THE
FUTURE NO THERE IS A CURRENTLY
DO NOT HAVE CERTIFICATION WE
STRONGLY PRESS AT THE DRAFT
LANGUAGE OF SECTION ONE TWO TWO
THREE NINE FIVE POINT TWO EIGHT
TWO TWO MINUTE DESPITE. THE
LANGUAGE THAT TRAINERS STATE.
WHETHER OR NOT ARE LICENSES. AND
WE THAT LANGUAGE BECAUSE THAT.
SIMPLY FOR DISCLOSE THEIR- TO
PURCHASE WHICH OF COURSE CAN
INCLUDE WHETHER THEY ARE
LICENSED OR CERTIFIED. WE
BELIEVE THAT TAKING THIS
AMENDMENT WOULD NOT WEAKEN THE
ATTENDED THE BILL BUT WOULD GO A
LONG WAY TOWARD ELIMINATING
FUTURE PROBLEMS AND CONFUSION.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES LINED- OH GO AHEAD
PLEASE THANKS. YOU'RE WELCOME
NINE THREE OH TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TORSIONAL ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN KENNEL
CLUB- WE USE WE REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION- LIKE MR GAMES WITH
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
OPTIMISED APPS- TIME AND
WILLINGNESS TO MAKE AMENDMENTS.
BUT WE DO HAVE THE SAME CONCERNS
REGARDING LICENSURE AND THAT-
INABILITY TO GET LICENSING IN
CERTAIN AREAS OF TRAINING THAT
WOULD. BECAUSE PERHAPS POTENTIAL
CUSTOMERS PAS WHEN THE THEY
DON'T HAVE A LICENSE FOR THE
LICENSE DOESN'T EXIST. AND FOR
THAT WE REMAIN OPPOSED THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AT NINE TWO EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS YES ORANGE
COUNTY IN THE PAST YEAR AND I AM
OPPOSED TO AB ONE ZERO NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ALSO THE NEED TO- THE LANGUAGE
CALIFORNIA. AND- I'M OPPOSED TO
THAT BILL. THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI IT WILL BE A
FAMILY MEMBER BE DISCIPLINED FOR
USING PROFANITY EARLIER. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER MIND
LINES IN Q. FOUR AB NINETEEN OH
ONE. GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BRING A BETTER BECAUSE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- YES MR
GRAYSON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR
OF PROTECTING OUR ANIMALS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY WHEN
THERE ARE CERTAIN EXPECTATIONS
WHEN YOU'RE SENDING YOUR PET OFF
TO BE TRAINED- I HEARD THE
COMMENTS FROM OPPOSITION AND I
THINK IT'S WELL NOTED. AND JUST
WANTED A COMMITMENT FROM YOU AS
THE AUTHOR THAT YOU WOULD
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH THEM AND
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF IT BECAUSE
IT SEEMS TO ME IF YOU'RE A
TRAINER YOU WOULD WANT TO
PROMOTE THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE A
CERTIFICATE OR YOU'VE BEEN
LICENSE IN A PARTICULAR AREA.
HOWEVER WE DON'T HAVE A FORMAL
LICENSURE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO JUST WITH YOUR
COMMITMENT I CAN SUPPORT THAT
BUILD OUT I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THEM THANK YOUNG-
RATIONING AT THOSE ARE GOING TO
BE MY CLOSING REMARKS ANYWAY SO
THANK YOU. IT IS ALL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. THING NINE MISSION IS
THERE YEAH MR WARD NO THANK YOU
AS WELL IT'S NOT REALLY WANTED
OF TELLING THAT AND- ECOLOGY N
FROM THE SAN DIEGO HUMANE
SOCIETY SOME OF THEIR ISSUES ON-
THAT I AND EVEN TEND TO BE ABLE
TO WORK ON OUR PLAN WILL BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT TODAY BUT SEE HOW
THAT DOES. MOVE FORWARD IN
SUPERMAN SAID AS YOUR- AS THIS
BILL HAD SOARED TO FOUR. THE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
. THING NINE MISTER NAZARIAN
WHEN YOU LOOK CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE I
APPRECIATE ONE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN HIS AREA AND
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON AMENDMENTS THE
PROPOSED THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WILL ENSURE THAT DOG
TRAINERS COMMUNICATE IMPORTANT
INFORMATION TO PET OWNERS BEFORE
PROVIDING PET TRAINING SERVICES.
I UNDERSTAND WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITMENTS TODAY AND WITH
THAT UNDERSTANDING OUTLOOK FOR
TO SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY
CREATED- AND WITH THAT MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN OH ONE
THE MOTION IS. IN ENGLISH WE
NEED A MOTION A SECOND. GOT A
MOTION GOT A SECOND. AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
BERMAN AYE BERMAN I FLORA
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM.
BONTA. TEN ABUTTING CUNNINGHAM
DALY. ALLEN NOW FONG. FONG NO
GIPSON GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
IRWIN- IRWIN KILEY MCCARTY
MEDINA MULLIN THANK WEBER.
HOWEVER I WHAT FOR NOW. OKAY
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. WITH THAT
WE HAVE DOCTOR QUIRK. FOR AGENDA
ITEMS NUMBER SEVEN AND EIGHT WHY
DON'T WE START WITH SEVEN A. B.
IN NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR IF THAT
PLEASES. THE AUTHOR. WITH SIX
ASSISTS YEAH BOB THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- FIRST I WANT TO
EXTEND MY APPRECIATION TO
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
CLOSELY WITH MY OFFICE ON THE
BILL OVERTAKING THE MEMBERS
PROPOSED BY THE COMMITTEE AND
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION YOUR DRESS CONCERNS
REST- REYES BY THE MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION LET ME SAY- NOT A
DARK NOT A MEDICAL DOCTOR
ASTROPHYSICS DOESN'T QUALIFY YOU
HERE. AND UNLESS YOU GET INPUT
FROM THE MEDICAL ASSOCIATION OF
YOU'RE NOT GONNA HAVE A GOOD
BILL AND- WE LIKE WHAT THEY
SUGGESTED AND- CERTAINLY THERE
THERE SHOULD BE LIMITS ON THE-
ON THE USE OF- PAIN KILLERS.
WITH CANNABIS BUT THERE CAN ALSO
BE IN IN MANY CASES A USER WHO
FINDS CANNABIS USEFUL AND COULD
GET TREATMENT FOR PAIN AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT-
I COULD GO ON BUT YOU HAVE A
LONG AGENDA WHY DON'T I JUST GO
TO MY WITNESSES THANK YOU DAVID
TESTIFYING IN AB NINETEEN FIFTY
FOUR OUR DOCTOR. LARRY THE DARD
MEDICAL DIRECTOR AND AUTHOR OF
SHE AT THE CMA RESOLUTION ON
CANNABIS AND- MAIN AS WELL AS
CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
FOR THE RAND HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT. AND IMPACTED PATIENT
RICHARD MILLER. PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU DR WORK. WHERE ONCE
AGAIN. MAYBE HIT THE BUTTON
RIGHT BY THE MIKE. I'M DOCTOR
LARRY BUT DARD- I'M EMERGENCY
POSITION SPEAKING AS AN
INDIVIDUAL AS WELL AS A CANNABIS
ADVOCATE THERE ARE THREE REASONS
WHY I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
ONE OF MEDICAL CANNABIS IS
EFFECTIVE IN TREATING CHRONIC
PAIN. TO MEDICAL CANNABIS IS A
VERY SAFE DRUGS AND THREE MANY
PEOPLE WITH CHRONIC PAIN WHO USE
MEDICAL CANNABIS REDUCE OR
ELIMINATE THEIR USE OF OPIOIDS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE NATIONAL
ACADEMY OF SCIENCES ENGINEERING
AND MEDICINE PUBLISHED REPORT
HEALTH EFFECTS OF CANNABIS AND
CANNABINOIDS THEY REVIEWED
FIFTEEN THOUSAND- ITEMS OF
RESEARCH AND FOUND CONCLUSIVE
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE THAT MEDICAL
CANNABIS WAS EFFECTIVE IN
TREATING CHRONIC PAIN. NAUSEA
DUE TO CHEMOTHERAPY AND MUSCLE
SPASM IN PEOPLE WITH MULTIPLE
SCLEROSIS THE STUDY IN GREAT
BRITAIN A FEW YEARS AGO LOOKED
AT DANGER OF DRUGS THE MOST
DANGEROUS TO AN INDIVIDUAL WAS
HEROIN THE MOST DANGEROUS TO
SOCIETY WAS ALCOHOL. CANNABIS
RANKED TENTH IS A DANGER TO AN
INDIVIDUAL IN ELEVENTH IS A
DANGER TO SOCIETY AND THIRD
THERE ARE AT LEAST THIRTY
STUDIES WHICH DOCUMENT THAT
PATIENTS WHO USE MEDICAL
CANNABIS SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE
THEIR USE OF OPIOIDS OR
COMPLETELY ELIMINATE THE NEED
FOR OPIOIDS I'D BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE OR ANY
MEMBERS WITH COPIES OF THESE
DOCUMENTS I THINK THERE. CENTRAL
DOCUMENTS WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT MEDICAL CANNABIS I THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
UP WE HAVE MISTER MILLER I
BELIEVE. THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING THE SEMI OPINION THE
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR WILL OPEN
THE DOOR OF COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE DOCTOR AND THE
PATIENT. MAKE SAFE AND INFORMED
DECISIONS FOR SENSIBLE AND
RESPONSIBLE MEDICAID HE
PRACTICES WITH THE OVERSIGHT.
HAVING WORKED AS A CANNABIS
COUNTLESS SLUR AT ONE OF THE
MOST REPUTABLE MEDICAL
DISPENSARIES HERE IN SACRAMENTO
FOR NINE YEARS. I'VE ENCOUNTERED. ASIAN SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY USE
MEDICAL CANNABIS. AND I'VE SEEN
ENDING SIGNIFICANT INCREASE OVER
THE LAST FIVE YEARS ON AN
AVERAGE OF THREE TO FIVE
PATIENTS PER WEEK. THAT ARE
BEING CUT OFF INDISCRIMINATE
AGAINST ENFORCED GENDER
UNNECESSARY PAIN WITH NO REMEDY
OR RECOURSE FOR THESE DOCTORS
ACTIONS I MYSELF AM A PATIENT
THAT SUFFERS FROM NEUROPATHY
SPINAL STENOSIS CHRONIC FLAREUP
OF SCIATICA PAIN DUE TO A SERIES
OF ACCIDENTS. I AM ALSO A
MEDICAL CANNABIS PATIENT HAS
BEEN DENIED MY ACCESS TO
OPIOIDS. BY THREE DIFFERENT
DOCTORS. EVEN THOUGH BY USING
CANNABIS I WAS ABLE TO REDUCE MY
OP- DONE TAKE BY 75% EVEN THOUGH
BY USNG CANNABIS I WAS ABLE TO
REDUCE THIS. USE OF OPIOIDS I
DID HAVE PROBLEMS WITH
INTRACTABLE NERVE PAIN AND
SOMETIMES THE ONLY THINGS THAT
WOULD WORK WOULD BE AN OPIOID OR
A- MUSCLE RELAXING. WE PUT AND I
BEEN DIPPING DENIED REPEATEDLY
BECAUSE OF MY MEDICAL USE OF
CANNABIS. THE TIME HAS COME
WHERE WE MUST CHANGE THE
PARADIGM JUST DID WAS DID WITH A
B. TWO FIFTY EIGHT THE ORGAN.
TRANSPLANT BILL AND CANNABIS. TO
CHANGE THE STIGMA AND REMOVE THE
DISCRIMINATION FOR THOSE
PATIENTS MOST IN NEED IT'S THE
ONLY HUMANITARIAN THING TO DO I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION IN THIS MATTER AND
I AM AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND- ANY I KNOW THAT. SO
ANY PRIMER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE OPEN UP
FOR A ANY YOU WANT TO ADD ON- IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. GOT A MOTION. THERE'S I
CAN'T GOT A SECOND PLEASE MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DENNIS LET US
REMEMBER WHAT THE CALIFORNIA-MEDICAL ASSOCIATION WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION TO THE
AUTHOR THE STAFF ON THE
COMMITTEE WITH THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS WERE REMOVING
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. SEEING
NONE- LET'S OPEN UP FOR THE
PHONE LINES OPERATOR HE OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES FOR A. B.
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR- BY DOCTOR
QUIRK ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION WHO WON OUT ON
THEIR NAME. ORGANIZATION THERE
WITH ANY IN A POSITION ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB NINETEEN FIFTY
FOUR. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT.
OR OPPOSITION AB NINETEEN FIFTY
FOUR. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. NINE THREE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME'S CHRISTINE NOT THAN I
AM IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD ALL. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
EDWIN WILL BONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINE THREE TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN RESTORING STERN IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB IN NINETEEN
FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE THREE NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS LAURIE BARBOZA AND AYE
OPPOSED AB TWO TWO TWO THREE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YEAH MY
NAME IS HELEN BUYERS AND I
OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO THREE.
THANK YOU AND JUST FOR FOLKS ARE
WATCHING AB TWO TWO TWO THREE IS
NOT ON OUR AGENDA TODAY. AND WE
ARE CURRENTLY HEARING AB ONE
NINE FIVE FOUR BY DR CORK. NINE
THREE NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS ABBY LEVY I AM OPPOSED OF AB
TWO TWO THREE THREE. OKAY I
THINK THANK YOU IF IT HAPPENS
AGAIN. I KNOW TWO FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS CAPTAIN
MCBRIDE WITH DESTINY CHRISTIAN
CHURCH AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. TWO TWO TWO THREE. OKAY THE
OPERATOR OH SORRY GO AHEAD. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT A. B.
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SO ALL BRING IT BACK
TO COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS- STARTING FROM MY
LEFT QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS GOING
TO MY RIGHT I DON'T SEE ANY
DOCTOR COURT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. ASPIRO VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'D LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSOR FOR WORKING
WITH US I AM WITH THE OPPOSITION
I CAN APPRECIATE THE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT PATIENTS GET THE
CARE THAT THEY NEED- I AND I
THINK THE AMENDMENTS HELP
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DIRECTION AND
CLARITY IN WITH THE ACCEPTED
AMENDMENTS I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY CAN WE PLEASE
CALL THE VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN. I
BERMAN HI FLORA. ARAMBULA WELL I
BLOOM. BONTA. TEN I'M NOT MONEY
CUNNINGHAM. DOLLY I FONG. FINE I
GIPSON GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
IRWIN- WHEN I LEAN MCCARTY
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN TANG.
WARD WORD I WEBER HOWEVER I.
WILL BE THE BILL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS- AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MOVE ON YOUR NEXT BILL ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY SIXTY.
YES THANK YOU EVERYONE THANK
YOU- SO AB TWENTY SIXTY. THANK
YOU KAREN MEMBERS ARE UNABLE TO
STAND MY APPRECIATION BOTH YOU
AND THE COMMITTEE AS USUAL OF
FOR WORKING CLOSELY WITH MY
OFFICE ON THIS BILL WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS WHICH
PROVIDE THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA FLEXIBILITY AND
DETERMINING- IT'S- DISCIPLINARY-
PANELS- MEMBERSHIP. OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA HAS RECEIVED HARSH
CRITICISM REGARDING ITS
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS AGAINST
PHYSICIANS IN RECENT YARS. SOME
CONSUMER ADVOCATES HAVE
INDICATED THAT THEY HAVE LOST
TRUST IN THE BOARDING OF CALLED
FOR REFORM ON MANY OF ITS
FUNCTIONS. AND THIS BILL IS
SEPARATE FROM ANY OF THAT. WE'RE
NOT TALKING HERE ABOUT. WHETHER
THE BOARD DOES A GOOD JOB OR
DOESN'T DO A GOOD JOB OR HAS THE
AUTHORITY OR DOESN'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITY. WHAT THIS IS ABOUT
IS- THE CALL TO ALL. IS TO- MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS. MORE
CONFIDENCE IN THE BOARD AND SO
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IS ASKING
THAT THE- BOARD EITHER AT B.
RIGHT NOW IT CAN HAVE AN EVEN
BALANCE BETWEEN LATE PEOPLE AND
MEDICAL PEOPLE. OR IT CAN HAVE
ONE ADDITIONAL MEDICAL PERSON
THIS WOULD MAKE IT SOUTHERLY THE
BNP EVEN BALANCE OR THERE WILL
BE ONE PERSON ONE MORE LAKEPORT.
AND THE IDEA HERE IS THAT.
CONSUMERS AND ADVOCATES CAN FEEL
THAT THE BOARD ITSELF IS WELL
BALANCED AND IS MAKING DECISIONS
IN THE INTEREST OF THE PUBLIC
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO SKIP ALL THE
OTHER STUFF THIS IS JUST ABOUT
GETTING CONFIDENCE IN THE BOARD
BACK. HI HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. IS CRISTINA LAWSON
PRESIDENT OF THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA. AND KAREN STEFANO
DIRECTOR OF THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION POLICY CENTER. AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO LAW
SCHOOL. THANK YOU DR COURT WHILE
WE START WITH MS LAWSON. THE
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
LAWSON I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA THE
BOARD IS PLEASED TO SPONSOR AB
TWENTY SIXTY AND IS GRATEFUL TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK FOR
AUTHORING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. THE BILL BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY IS ONE OF THE
NUMEROUS REQUESTS FOR
LEGISLATION THAT THE BOARD
DISTRIBUTED THE LEGISLATURE AT
THE BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR THE
BOARD'S REQUESTED STATUTORY
CHANGES WILL HELP RESTORE TRUST
IN THE BOARD BY HELPING TO
ENSURE IT HAS THE FINANCIAL
MEANS AND ENFORCEMENT TOOLS.
NECESSARY TO ADEQUATELY PROTECT
THE PUBLIC THE BILL BEFORE YOU
TODAY IS INTENDED TO INCREASE
CONFIDENCE IN THE BOARD'S
OPERATIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORK
NOTICES THE BOARD HAS BEEN UNDER
INCREASING SCRUTINY ESPECIALLY
IN RECENT YEARS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AND FROM NUMEROUS
PUBLIC STAKEHOLDERS. LAST YEAR
DURING OUR BOARD SUNSET REVIEW
PROCESS AND THE PROCESS TO
CONFIRM SEVEN OF OUR BOARD
MEMBERS BY THE SENATE WE FACED
QUESTIONS ABOUT A VARIETY OF
TOPICS INCLUDING WHETHER THE
BOARD IS SUFFICIENTLY FOCUSED ON
ITS MISSION OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION. AS DISCUSSED IN THE
BILL'S ANALYSIS AND REFLECTED IN
RECENT MEDIA COVERAGE MANY ARGUE
THAT OUR LICENSEES AND THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT REPRESENT
THEM HAVE TOO MUCH INFLUENCE ON
BOARD POLICY. ALTHOUGH THE BOARD
DISAGREES WITH THIS CRITICISM WE
RECOGNIZE THAT MANY HAVE LOST
TRUST IN THE BOARD AND QUESTION
WHETHER WE HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
PRIORITIES. CHANGING THE
COMPOSITION OF THE BOARD TO MOVE
FROM A PHYSICIAN MEMBER MAJORITY
TO A PUBLIC MEMBER MAJORITY IS
SUPPORTED BY CONSUMER ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS AND WE HOPE THAT
IT WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT AND
MEANINGFUL STEPS TO HELP
REASSURE THE PUBLIC THAT THE
BOARD IS ADEQUATELY FOCUSED ON
ITS MISSION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND ON BEHALF OF
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU MISTER MS
LAWSON AND THANK YOU FOR SERVING
ON THE BOARD- AND I BELIEVE THE-
CARE AND STEPHANO- BY PHONE
OPERATOR IF YOU CAN IDENTIFY.
THE STEPHANOS LINE- AND OPEN
THAT UP THAT BE GREAT. THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
FINO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
BERMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBER
THANK YOU FOR. GET TESTIFY- I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION. R. AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF SAN DIEGO SCHOOL OF LAW WORK
NONPROFIT NONPARTISAN ACADEMIC
AND ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION.
OFFERS I WANT TO COMMAND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK FOR.
HAVING THE COURAGE AND
DEMONSTRATING THE LEADERSHIP AND
AUTHORING THIS BILL AS WELL AS
THE WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE IN
SUBSTANTIAL COMPROMISE TO GET IT
THROUGH SHE HAS STATED AND LINDA
GREEN THAT CONSUMER PROTECTION
BOARDS SHOULD BE COMPOSED OF A
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC RATHER
THAN DOES A CONFESSION THEY
REGULATE. I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN WITH THIS BILL.
I BET. L. THROUGH COMMITTEE. I
KNOW YOU ALL KNOW THAT THE
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA ARE
WATCHING AND THIS ISSUE IS NOT
GOING TO GO AWAY. CONSUMER
GROUPS ARE WATCHING- LORD KNOWS
THE L. A. TIMES WAS WATCHING-
BANK- DAX DAX YET I AYE URGENT
AYE VOTE AND- I. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I DON'T SEE ANY PRIMARY WIN
THIS PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SO WHILE WE OPEN UP
TO THE FOLKS IN THE HEARING ROOM
FIRST YOU WANT TO ADD ON EITHER
IN SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL- REMINDER FOR FOLKS
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE WITH AND YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM SEEING NINE
LET'S OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES-
OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE WHO.
WANTS TO- I TO A UNITED TO BE A
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION OR IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY SIXTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY SIXTY.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIXTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. NINE EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS RECTANGLE
REPRESENTING A VOICE FOR CHOICE
ADVOCACY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIXTY THANK YOU SO MUCH. MINUTE
FOR EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MARY ANN HOLLINGSWORTH AND
THE PATIENT SAFETY ADVOCATE IN
THE SAN DIEGO AREA AND I AM IN
FAVOR OF AB TWENTY SIXTY THANK
YOU. NINE FOUR FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FOUR FOURTEEN YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WILL
MOVE ON BOTH THIRTY GOAL LINE
FOR FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MOVING ON TO LINE THREE FORTY
ONE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
SUSAN LAUREN ON THE PATIENT
SAFETY ACTIVISTS FROM THE LOS
ANGELES AREA AND I AM IN STRONG
FAVOR OF THIS- AMENDMENTS AND-
AS LONG AS IT'S A NON CONFLICTED
PUBLIC MEMBER. IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT I'M IN FAVOR OF IT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CAN
TELL STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. NINE
THREE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS MICHELLE MONTARA RUNNERS ON
WITH CONSUMER WATCHDOG AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIXTY
THANK YOU. ONE THREE NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING COUNTY
SMACKING THE CONSUMER WATCHDOG
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIXTY THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU THIS IS SCOTT
OLSON WITH CONSUMER WATCHDOG AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT TWENTY SIXTY
. ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS MONIQUE HINES I AM FROM
BAKERSFIELD I AM A VOLUNTEER
WITH CONSUMER WATCHDOG IN MY
VIEW THE OPTICALLY SUPPORT AB
TWENTY SIXTY IN MEMORY OF MY
PARENTS ABOUT. NINE FIFTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HEY THERE ISN'T ANYTHING
I MAY OTHER THAN BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA AND I AM A VOLUNTEER
WITH CONSUMER WATCHDOG AS WELL
AS THE ONE OF THE FOUNDERS OF
HOSPITAL WATCHDOG AND I. SUPPORT
AB TWENTY SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
NINE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MARK WILSON
RETIRED EXECUTIVE WITH TACO BELL
I LIVE IN NEWPORT BEACH-
CALIFORNIA AND I AM- VOLUNTEER
ALSO WITH CONSUMER WATCHDOG AND
I USE THE ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT A.
B. TWO SIXTY. SUPPORT INTO
NEUTRALIZE- THE DOCTORS GOOD OLE
BOY NETWORK IN THIS IS A KEY
FOUNDATION FOR THAT THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS OKAY AIRY AND I'M TO SAN
FRANCISCO I'M A VOLUNTEER WITH
CONSUMER WATCHDOG I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIXTY THANK
YOU. NINE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS SANDEEP CARESS CALLING
FROM HIS BERIA CALIFORNIA I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH CONSUMER WATCHDOG
DOCTOR SHOULD NOT POLICE OTHER
DOCTORS AMERICANS LOSING
STICKLEY SUPPORT AB. TWO ZERO
SIX ZERO IN MEMORY OF MY
DAUGHTER JORDAN. MYND FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME'S
EXECUTIVE FROM BAKER SO I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH CONSUMER WATCHDOG
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
TWENTY SIX. NINE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS KIMBERLY
TRIPPIN AND- EIGHT PATIENTS AT
THE CONSUMER WATCHDOG WILL
COUNTY COURT. I AB CONVO BEL IN
MEMORY. YOU CAN GET NOW COULDN'T
GET AND AGREEMENT ABOUT THANK
YOU. MINA FOR ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ERIC ANDERSON TO PATIENT SAFETY
LEAGUE AND I WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT IF AMENDED AND
APPARENTLY DOES NOT REQUIRE THE
LEGISLATOR GOVERNOR TO ACTUALLY
PLACE A PUBLIC MEMBER IMPOSITION
IN A TIMELY FASHION THE BOARD
HAD PUBLIC POSITIONS OPEN FOR
YEARS NOW AND NOBODY'S BEEN PUT
IN THE POSITION. THANK YOU. NINE
THREE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ROGER SO FAR I'M FROM LOS
ANGELES THE BOMB SHE WAS THE
CONSUMER WATCHDOG AND ALSO LOOK
AT THEM OF DENTAL MEDICAL
MALPRACTICE I GET TO THE US TO
DO SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIXTY.
THANK YOU. NINE THREE TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS CAROL BRADLEY
I LIVE IN REDWOOD SHORES
CALIFORNIA I'M A VOLUNTEER WITH
CONSUMER WATCHDOG AND I.
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIXTY
THANK YOU. NINE ONE TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DENISE JOHNSON I LIVE IN TRACY
CALIFORNIA I AM A VOLUNTEER WITH
THE COMPUTE CONSUMER WATCHDOG
AND I STRONGLY ENTHUSIASTICALLY
SUPPORT A. B. TWENTY SIXTEEN. IN
MEMORY OF MY SON RICHARD THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MIND TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS TINA MINASSIAN FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I'M A
SURVIVOR OF MEDICAL HARD AND A
VOLUNTEER WITH CONSUMER WATCHDOG
I STRONGLY AND ENTHUSIASTICALLY
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIXTEEN. NINE
ONE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
EVELYN MARTINEZ AND I MEAN I'M
AND YOU'RE A CONSUMER WATCHDOG I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY
SIXTEEN IN MEMORY OF MY SON
HOLDING. THANK YOU. NINE FOUR OH
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING I'M
CALLING- FOR ANY- REPRESENTING
THE PARENTS OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
REMOVING ALL OF THESE EVIL BILLS
THAT YOU ARE TRYING TO PUSH OUR
CHILDREN. OKAY YOUR DOCTOR WILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN Q. EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY SIXTY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'LL BRING IT BACK TO COLLEGE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
STARTING ON MY LEFT. GOING TO MY
RIGHT DR WEBER. THANK YOU CHAIR
AND DAD THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION TODAY I THINK-
WE ALL KNOW THAT THAT THERE IS
SOME SIGNIFICANT CHANGES AND
IMPROVEMENTS THAT NEED TO HAPPEN
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
BOARD. I'M NOT REALLY QUITE SURE
IF THIS IS THE RIGHT PATH BUT I
DO HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
FOR YOU. CERTAINLY I'M HOW MANY
OTHER PROFESSIONAL BOARDS ARE
COMPOSED OF THAT PRIMARILY A
PUBLIC MAJORITY- I DO NOT NOW
AND- THIS IS. THIS IS ONE BILL
FOR ME. AND IF YOU CAN PLEASE
TELL ME OKAY THANK YOU SO-
ACUPUNCTURE BEHAVIORAL SCIENCE
VOCATIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS HAVE A
PUBLIC MAJORITY LICENSE MAJORITY
CHIROPRACTIC DENTAL BOARD DENTAL
HYGIENISTS MEDICAL BOARD RURAL
PASSED OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
OPTOMETRY- NBC PHARMACY PHYSICAL
THERAPY PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS
PODIATRY PSYCHOLOGY B. R. N. S.
L. P. H. A. D. AND VETERINARY
MEDICINE. AND THERE'S ALSO A
BILL THAT I GUESS WE WILL HERE
AT SOME POINT ABOUT ESTABLISHING
A MIDWIFERY BOARD WHICH THEY ARE
PROPOSING FIVE MIDWIVES TO
PUBLIC- MEMBERS. I'M HOW MANY
TIMES HAS A JUDGMENT OR A VOTE
FOR A DISCIPLINARY ACTION AN OFF
BY ONE VOTE. THAT'S A QUESTION
FOR ME I UNFORTUNATEL DON'T
HAVE THAT INFORMATION AVAILABLE-
I WILL SAY THAT THAT WITH
RESPECT TO THIS PARTICULAR BILL-
THE PURPOSE IS NOT TO CHANGE THE
OUTCOME- NECESSARILY IT IS TO
RESTORE CONFIDENCE IN THE BOARD
AND ITS PROFIT. SO YOU'RE SAYING
THAT CHANGING THE COMPOSITION
ISN'T GOING TO CHANGE WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THE BOARD WITH THE
OUTCOME OF THE BOARD IT IS WITH
THE VOTES WILL BE ARE THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS NOT TO
CHANGE THE OUTCOMES OF THE
BOARD'S DECISION OF COURSE
ADDING ADDITIONAL PUBLIC MEMBER
VOICE WHICH COULD CHANGE THE
COMPOSITION OF THE BOARD- AND
EACH OF THE INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS
BRING THEIR OWN YOU KNOW
PERSPECTIVES- TO THOSE PANEL
DECISIONS BUT WE DON'T AT THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS NOT TO
CHANGE THE OUTCOME. OF THE BOARD
NECESSARILY IF TO RESTORE
CONFIDENCE IN THE BOARD. ROOM
OKAY SO EVEN WITH THE CHANGE THE
WHAT THE ISSUES WERE STILL
POTENTIALLY BE THERE. IT'S
POSSIBLE OKAY- SO THE L. A.
TIMES NOTED- ONE OF THE OTHER
ISSUES IS THAT THERE IS A DELAY-
SIGNIFICANT DELAY IN THEIR
RESPONSE TO COMPLAINT DO WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THE CHANGE IN
THE COMPOSITION OF THE BOARDS
WILL IMPROVE THAT. I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT TO BE. I'M YOU KNOW
THE BOARD OR BOARDS HAVE MANY
ROLES OUTSIDE OF JESS A
DISCIPLINARY ACTION SO THE
MEDICAL BOARD IS ALSO IN CHARGE
OF APPROVING UNDERGRADUATE AND
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS APPROVING CLINICAL
CLERKSHIPS AND SPECIAL PROGRAMS
AND HOSPITALS ADMINISTERING THE
BOARD'S CONTINUING MEDICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAM RCM MEANS I'M
AND I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY WHY
MOST BOARDS ARE COMPOSED OF
THOSE THAT ARE ACTUALLY IN THE
PROFESSION NOT JUST THE
DISCIPLINARY THING BUT THE OTHER
ASPECTS OF THE BOARD ITSELF- AND
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT THE NOTION
AND I GUESS THAT'S IS NOT WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING THAT THAT
PHYSICIANS- WOULD SEIZE. A AND
AN ACT- AND NOT DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT OR THAT THAT WE DON'T
RECOGNIZE THAT WHEN A PATIENT IS
HARMED IS NOT JUST THE PATIENT
AS THE FAMILY AS A COMMUNITY BUT
IT'S ALSO OUR PRACTICE AND THAT
WE WOULD NOT ACT ON THAT I GUESS
WE'RE NOT STATING THAT THAT IS
THE CASE- IT'S JUST FOR PUBLIC
PERCEPTION. WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
WOULD BE A VERY MEANINGFUL STEP
IN RESTORING THE PUBLIC'S
CONFIDENCE IN THE BOARD THE
BOARD HAS FACED. INCREASING
SCRUTINY AS I MENTIONED YOU KNOW
OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS
CERTAINLY. OVER THE COURSE OF
THE SIX YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN ON
THIS BOARD- AND WE DO BELIEVE
THE BOARD UNANIMOUSLY AGREES IN
FACT ALL OF ITS POSITION MEMBERS
ALL OF ITS PUBLIC MEMBERS. AGREE
THAT THIS IS IMPORTANT STAFF-
FOR THE PUBLIC. BUT IT WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY CHANGE THE OTHER
THINGS THAT THE PUBLIC IS
LOOKING FOR WHICH IS AN
IMPROVEMENT IN THE TIME OF
DEALING WITH THE COMPLAINTS OR
AN IMPROVEMENT IN THE TYPES OF
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS. THAT THAT
THAT THE PATIENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
HARMED. FEEL SHOULD BE DONE
THAT'S CORRECT THIS THIS
LEGISLATION IS AT ONE OF A
NUMBER OF MEASURES- THAT WE
BELIEVE- WOULD BE IMPORTANT IF
YOU KNOW IN ORDER TO BOTH. TO
REDUCE THOSE TIMES MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE BOARD ARE
THOSE ARE ALL INCLUDED IN THE
MEMO THAT WE DISTRIBUTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE I IN JANUARY OF THIS
YEAR. OKAYBUT THIS BILL DOESN'T
DO THAT DOESN'T DO IT ON ITS OWN
RIGHT NOW BUT IT'S AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THAT PACKAGE RIGHT OKAY
ALL RIGHT. I'M WELL THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD I DO
THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME OTHER
BILLS THAT DO SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESS CERTAIN ISSUES- ONE OF
WHICH WE HEARD EARLIER TODAY
WHICH DEALT WITH. YOU KNOW
PHYSICIANS THAT SEXUALLY ASSAULT
PATIENTS YOU KNOW NOT GETTING
THEIR LICENSURE BACK- I DO THINK
THAT IT IS IMPORTANT TO RESTORE
CONFIDENCE BUT I THINK THAT THE
WAY IN WHICH WE RESTORE
CONFIDENCE. IS ACTUALLY MAKING
SURE THAT THOSE PHYSICIANS WHO
SHOULD NOT BE PRACTICING ARE NOT
PRACTICING AND THAT WE ARE-
RESPONDING. PLANTS AT THE
FASHION IN A CHANGING THE
COMPOSITION OF THE BOARD ISN'T
GOING TO DO THAT THEN I'M NOT
SURE THAT. IT'S THE BEST OUT BUT
I DO APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS AND ANSWER MY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK DR WEBER. ANY
ADDITIONAL. IMMENSE SEEING NINE
THIRTY WORK WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SURE BOB. AS MY WITNESS
HERE SAID THERE'S A WHOLE PACK
AND DR WEBER'S BILL WILL BE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THAT- AND I
PARTICULARLY RESPECT DR WEBER AS
A PHYSICIAN AND DOCTOR ARAMBULA
WHO'S ALSO ON THIS- COMMITTEE.
AND YOU KNOW I CAN ONLY DO SO
MUCH WITH THIS BILL IT WILL NOT
CURE EVERYTHING IT DOES IF THERE
IF THERE WERE. A BIG
DISAGREEMENT BETWEEN THE MEDICAL
FOLKS AND V- LAKE PEOPLE ON THE
BOARD. THE MEDICAL FOLKS WON'T
BE ABLE TO OUT VOTE THE LAY
PEOPLE. THAT'S TRUE HOW OFTEN
THAT HAPPENS I DON'T KNOW- I
THINK AGAIN THERE ARE MANY OTHER
BILLS THAT ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
TO SOLVING THIS. THIS DOES
GUARANTEE THAT YOU JUST CAN'T
HAVE DOCTORS ALONE RAM SOMETHING
THROUGH THAT THE LATE PEOPLE
DON'T AGREE WITH. SO IN THAT IT
DOES DO SOMETHING. ARE IT
DOESN'T DO AS MUCH AS YOU'RE
DOING AND THERE ARE A WHOLE
BUNCH OF BILLS THEY'RE GOING TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM AND I WANNA
SAY THIS. IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
THE MEDICAL BOARD. REALIZES
THERE ARE PROBLEMS AND WANTS TO
SOLVE THEM AND THIS IS JUST. ONE
OF MANY BILLS PERHAPS NOT THE
MOST IMPORTANT AND THAT'S FINE.
BUT I DO THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT DOES SHOW YOU CAN'T
HAVE DOCTORS OVERWHELMINGLY P.
THANK YOU DR COURT. SOME
ELEMENTS ARE BY SAYING I
APPRECIATE THE MEDICAL BOARD'S
EFFORTS TO BE PROACTIVE ABOUT
IMPROVING ITS RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE PUBLIC AND AS WE'VE HEARD
TODAY THERE'S A DEBATE. ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THIS BILL WILL
SUBSTANTIVELY CHANGED THE
DECISION MAKING BY THE BOARD
HOWEVER I BELIEVE THAT
PERCEPTION IS ALSO IMPORTANT-
WHEN IT COMES TO BUILDING TRUST
AT THE SAME TIME I URGE YOU TO
CONTINUE TO CONSIDER THE
IMPORTANCE OF PRESERVING THE
VOICE OF PHYSICIANS WHEN IT
COMES TO APPLYING THE STANDARD
OF CARE- AND I HOPE THAT DEBATE
CONTINUES AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. IN THE MEANTIME WITH
THE AUTHORS ACCEPTANCE OF THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS I'M I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
WITH THAT DO WE HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND WE NEED A MOTION AND
SECOND. OUR MOTION GOT A SECOND
MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN. HI BERMAN
I FLOOR FLOOR AYE ARAMBULA.
BLOOM BONTA CHEN I'M NOT VOTING
CUNNINGHAM. SALLY HI FONG. ON
AYE GIPSON. GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
IRWIN. BERMAN I AM. WHEN I. LEE
MCCARTY DANA MEDINA AYE MULLIN
MULLIN HIGHER HAIN WARD WARD I
AND WEBER. ANOTHER THING THAT
BILL IS OUT I BELIEVE THAT BILL
IS OUT WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
EVERYONE AND THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER YOUR I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE EFFORT YOU'RE MAKING. NEXT
UP WE HAVE ITEM- CHEN I'M NUMBER
NINE AB TWENTY EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SOME NUMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
THANK YOU HI MISTER CHAIR I AND
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB AT TWO ZERO EIGHT
SEVEN WHICH WILL PROTECT LIVES
BY ENSURING THAT THE LEVEL OF
CARE SOLD TO PATIENTS ALIGNS
WITH WHAT IS BEING ADVERTISED BY
PROVIDERS IN WITH THEIR LICENSE
TO DELIVER- I'D FIRST LIKE TO
THANK YOUR STAFF ASKING YOURSELF
FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL AND IT THAT I WILL BE
ACCEPTING. COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
I NEED FOR THIS BILL IS
PARTICULARLY ACUTE IN BUSINESSES
THAT ARE OFFERING A DRUG AND
ALCOHOL TREATMENT SERVICES AND
I'M ALL SURE JUST JUST ONE STORY
BY WAY OF EXAMPLE. I IN MY
DISTRICT LACKS LAST AUGUST A
TWENTY THREE YEAR OLD MAN WHO
WAS LIVING IN AN ADDICTION
TREATMENT FACILITY IN NEWPORT
BEACH LEFT THE PREMISES AT
EXHIBITING SIGNS OF PARANOID TO
LARRY I'M HAVING NOT RECEIVED A
COCKTAIL OF CONTRAINDICATED
MEDICATIONS. TRAGICALLY HE BROKE
DOWN THE DOOR OF A NEARBY
RESIDENTS AND- WAS SHOT AND
KILLED BY THE NEIGHBOR- IT'S
CLEAR THAT THIS YOUNG MAN SHOULD
HAVE BEEN IN THIS FACILITY WITH
MUCH GREATER SUPERVISION VISION
MONITORING OF HIS DETOX- THIS
TRAGIC EXAMPLE. REALLY DOES
HIGHLIGHT I IN MY MIND THE NEED
FOR THIS BILL AND I NEED FOR US
TO STRENGTHEN OVERSIGHT WHEN IT
COMES TO THE DISTRIBUTION OF
MEDICATIONS PARTICULARLY IN
RECOVERY RESIDENTS AS- OP ONE
THING THAT WE HAVE SEEN IS THAT
RIGHT NOW IT IS CURRENTLY AN UP
HILL BATTLE TO STOP THESE
DANGEROUS AND UNFAIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES. AND AT PATIENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES REALLY ARE BEST
POSITIONED TO IDENTIFY ROGUE
PRACTICES AND ROGUE FACILITIES
ARE FALSE ADVERTISEMENT ON
PROVIDING SERVICES BY UNTRAINED
OR AND LICENSE STAFF REALLY IS
ON ACCEPTABLE AND DANGEROUS AND
WE'VE GOT TO PROVIDE A PATH TO
STOP THESE PRACTICES AND THESE
UNSCRUPULOUS OPERATORS. ON THIS
BILL DOES THAT BY DOING A COUPLE
OF THINGS A NUMBER ONE ENABLING
PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES YOU
TAKE CIVIL ACTION TO HOLD
UNSCRUPULOUS RECOVERY FACILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR DISPENSING
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS WITHOUT A
LICENSE OR FALSELY ADVERTISING A
LEVEL OF CARE. AND NUMBER TWO
AUTHORING THE RECOVERY OF
ATTORNEY FEES TO A PREVAILING
PLAINTIFF. ON JOINING US RIGHT
NOW TO TESTIFY AMERICANS LIVE
INDIVIDUALS WHO. HAVE I
EXPERIENCED. THESE BROKE
FACILITIES I WENDY MCINTIRE'S
SON JARED PASSED AWAY IN A ROGUE
SOBER LIVING HOME. AND WE HAVE
NAMES BY THE SPELL CHERUSCI IN
HIS HONOR AND MEMORY. I'M AND
WE'RE ALSO JOINED BY CHRISTIAN
ACHESON WHO IS A FORMER RECOVERY
PATIENT- TWENTY THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. HI MY NAME IS LENNY
MCINTYRE ON THE PUBLIC SAFETY
ADVOCATE IN CALIFORNIA. I'M HERE
BECAUSE OF GERAS LAW I'M- MY SON
DIED FROM AN OVERDOSE IN A SOBER
LIVING HOME SEVENTEEN YEARS AGO
THE STAFF RESPONSIBLE FOR HIS
KERR DID NOTHING TO SAVE A
REVIVED HIM HE WAS LEFT OUT
SPREADING FOR HOURS ALONE UNTIL
HIS LAST BREATH ALL WHILE THE
FIRE DEPARTMENT WAS JUST TWO
BLOCKS AWAY BUT WHENEVER CALLED.
THIS COMPLETE NEGLIGENCE AND
LACK OF CARE OPENED MY EYES TO
THE UNFORTUNATE FACT THAT I AM
NOT ALONE FAMILIES CONTINUED TO
SEND THEIR LOVED ONES TO
TREATMENT IN HOPES OF THEM
FINALLY GETTING HELP. ONLY THEIR
LOVED ONES ARE FACING
CIRCUMSTANCES MUCH WORSE THAN
ADDICTION. AFTER STARTING HERE
AS LONG. I HAD MADE A STARTLING
DISCOVERY ABOUT TREATMENT
FACILITIES THAT DECEIVE THE
PUBLIC SO THEY CAN PROFIT OFF
VULNERABLE PEOPLE. THE WORST
PART IS THAT DEATHS THAT SOBER
LIVING HOMES AND TREATMENT
FACILITIES CONTINUE TO PILE UP.
AND SEEM TO GO UNNOTICED
BECAUSE- NOTHING PREVENTS FROM
THE PUBLIC FROM BEING PROPERLY
INFORMED ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT A PROPER
LEVEL OF TREATMENT HAS RECEIVED
FOR PEOPLE SEEKING RECOVERY AT
THE FACILITIES ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS.
WE NEED TO CLOSE THE LOOPHOLE
THAT WOULD REQUIRE A LICENSE IF
MEDICATIONS ARE BEING
ADMINISTERED. CURRENTLY
FACILITIES ARE MAKING PATIENTS
SELF ADMINISTER THEIR OWN
MEDICATIONS TO AVOID LICENSURE.
THIS IS EXTREMELY DANGEROUS
PRACTICE AND IT NEEDS TO STOP. I
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLYWOMAN CARDI
PETRIE-NORRIS FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT AND DOGGED DETERMINATION
FOR PROTECTING. ALL OF OUR LOVED
ONES AND I WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER ACHESON. AND DO YEAH I
HAD THE BUTTON RIGHT THERE THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME'S CHRISTIAN
ADDISON- FROM SAN DIEGO I ALSO
APPLIED ASSEMBLY WOMAN BUT A
PATRON ARSES- INITIATIVES WITH
THE CARE AND THE CONTINUITY OF
CARE. IS RECOVERY HOMES. NEED TO
HAVE- I HAD RESPONDED TO AN
ADVERTISEMENT BY PACIFIC SHORES
RECOVERY LOC HEADERS HOUSING
SUBSTANCE ABUSE. CARE AND MENTAL
HEALTH CARE- AS A LICENSED SIX
BED FACILITY WITH THE STAFF AT
THIRTEEN. I RISE SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY THEY HAD
ADVERTISED FOR HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER SIX MONTH
PROGRAM I HAD BEEN ADMITTED FOR
POSSIBLE SURGERY ACROSS THE
STREET AT HOAG HOSPITAL FOR A
BURKE VERTICAL BURST FRACTURE
THAT HAPPENED MONTHS PRIOR- HAND
FOR A TREATMENT- FOR MY- MOST
MATIC STRESS AND- THE WAY I
HANDLED MY PAIN. UPON
ADMITTANCE- WITNESS THERE WAS A
COED FACILITY IN ONE BUILDING
HOUSING TWELVE MALES AND TWELVE
FEMALES IN ADDITION TO THE SIX
BED LICENSED FACILITY THAT I WAS
IN. OUR BECAME AWARE THAT- DID-
THEY WERE HOME OFFERING
FRAUDULENTLY THROUGH ADVERTISING
PROP PROVIDING MEDICAL SERVICES
FOR THIRTY TO SEVENTY FIVE
PEOPLE BETWEEN COSTA MESA AND A
NEWPORT BEACH AND ADJACENT TO
THE SANTA ANA HEIGHTS
NEIGHBORHOOD. THAT SAW- BEEN
PROBLEMATIC THERE WAS A HOUSE
TECH. WORKING OUT OF THE GARAGE
MINISTERING MORNING NOON AND
EVENING MEDS ADMINISTERING
MONITORING AND LOGGING FOR
COMPLIANCE MEDICATION FOR
COMPLIANCE MEDICATIONS IN THE
GARAGE AT THE- LICENSE AND ON
PERMITTED. AND- AND- NAY S.
SANCTIONED- HOME IN COSTA MESA-
THEY WERE OPERATING IS A HYBRID
AFTER COST OF ACES JUNCTION AND
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO BE JUST A
LANDLORD THEY WERE MARAJ WHEN I
WAS CURRENT BECAUSE OF HOUSE
POLICY THE DOCTOR INCREASE IT
DOES CHANGING THE MEDS AND TOOK
MEDS AWAY WITHOUT. ARM WAITING
FOR- EFFICACY OR FROM A WORD
FROM MY PSYCHIATRIST AT THE
VETERANS ADMINISTRATION- IN
OUTSIDE MEDICAL PROTOCOL I WAS
CURBED BY THE AHA CEO WELL AFTER
THEY KERR ME MANAGER SAID THEY
CONTINUE TO ORDER MEDICATIONS IN
MY NAME I WAS HOMELESS FOR THREE
WEEKS WITHOUT THEM KNOWING WHERE
MY WHEREABOUTS UNTIL I. WAS
RECEIVED AT NORTHBOUND RECOVERY
WHOM THEY ARE INTEGRAL AND
AFFILIATED WITH INCONSISTENT
WITH OPERATING. BY- ON
INCONSISTENT WITH- A COMMUNITY
CARE FACILITIES. EMPLOYING A
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR STAFF SO WITH
A LEGITIMATE RATIO OF STAFF TO
CLIENT. THEY ONLY EMPLOYED
THIRTEEN. R. ONE DOCTOR ONE
PRIMARY CARE TO SOCIAL WORKERS
PROPER TO SEVENTY FIVE PEOPLE.%
HE TRIED TO COST ME THOUSANDS
AND MAYBE HOMELESS THEIR LACK OF
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS CAUSE
FURTHER DAMAGE TO MY VERTEBRAE
AND OTHER CLIENTS TO WHICH I AM
AWARE OF. A DIED WITHIN A SIX
MONTH PERIOD IN IN BOTH- FROM
BOTH COSTA MESA AND THEIR
NEWPORT BEACH FACILITIES- THEY
FEIGNED ENTITLEMENT TO
CONSTITUTIONAL REMEDIES AND
PROTECTIONS. WERE DENIED
CONTINUED OPERATIONS. IN A.
PARDON ME- MAYBE IT IF YOU GET A
CHANCE MAYBE TO CONCLUDE THAT BE
GREAT THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO
DO. THEY HAD FAINT. FAINT
ENTITLEMENT TO CONSTITUTIONAL
REMEDIES AND PROTECTIONS. IN THE
NINTH CIRCUIT AND CONTINUE THEIR
OPERATIONS DESPITE LOCAL LAW
AND- THANK YOU FOR HEARING ME
THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU MISTER ROGERS AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE THANK YOU-
LET'S OPEN IT TOO I DON'T HAVE
ANY WITNESSES POWER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SO IT'S OPEN TO
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
TODAY WHO WANT TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. ANYBODY WANT TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL IN THE HEARING ROOM TODAY.
NOT SEEING ANYONE. IF OT OF THE
PHONE LINES OPERATOR IF THERE'S
ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL BY. STATING YOUR NAME-
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH IF ANY
AND POSITION ON THE BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY EIGHTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY EIGHTY SEVEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT THAT ZERO. ONE
ONE MOMENT FOR OUR FIRST COMMENT.
WILL BE A FEW MOMENTS WHILE WE
GATHER THE LINE NUMBERS THANK
YOU.
WE HAD A FEW PEOPLE MOVE IN AND
OUT OF THE COMMENT QUEUE. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON.
AB TWENTY EIGHTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME NINE FOUR SEVENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M LAURIE DURAN AND WITH
ADVOCATES FOR RESPONSIBLE
TREATMENT A COMPARATIVE. THAT WE
ENSURE THAT. RECOVERING ADDICTS
ARE PROTECTING YOU WOULD ASK THE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE I HONESTLY
THANK YOU. NINE FORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS NANCY CLARK I HAVE WORKED IN
THE RECOVERY FIELD FOR FORTY
SEVEN YEARS I'M THE OPERATOR OF
A LICENSED RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
PROGRAM FOR THIRTY TWO YEARS AS
WELL AS AN OUTPATIENT PROGRAM I
AM VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL
I APPLAUD. THE MEASURES THAT ARE
BEING TAKEN TO IMPROVE THE
SAFETY IN THIS INDUSTRY AND I
ENCOURAGED IT COULD NOT STOP
HERE THANK YOU WE NEED MORE OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU JUST A
REMINDER TO FOLKS WE'VE HAD TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT SO
IF YOU KEEP IT IS JUST YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH IF ANY
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
THAT WOULD BE FANTASTIC. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
ON AB TWENTY EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SO BRING IT BACK
TO COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS START
ON MY RIGHT THIS TIME. STARTING
TOMORROW RIGHT COMING AROUND MY
LEFT. NOT SEEING ANY. MISDEEDS
NORTH WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU ARE I WILL JUST CLOSE
BY RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU- YOU THINK
YOU- AND THEN YOU THE SPONSORS
AND THANK YOU TO THE WITNESSES.
MOVING THIS MEASURE FOR IN
WORKING WITH US ON THE
AMENDMENTS I SUPPORT WITH THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO DO- ABSOLUTELY
AND APPRECIATE THE NEED TO
REGULATE BAD ACTORS. TO PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM BEING HARMED WHEN
SEEKING CARE. THAT SAID THE END
AND- MYSTERIES NORTH YOU AND
I'VE I'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION-
INCLUDING THE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY WOULD
HAVE BENEFITTED FROM REVIEW BY
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. SO
GOING FORWARD I ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSOR TO WORK
WITH THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEES OF
THE ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE- ON
FURTHER REFINEMENTS IF NECESSARY
BUT WITHOUT HAVING TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AND MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE VOTE. I WOULD I WOULD
IMAGINE A SECOND LESSON WE DO WE
NEED WE NEED A MOTION A SECOND.
GOT A MOTION SIR MEDINA AND TO
SAY I THINK MR MULLIN. NOW LET'S
CALL THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN AYE BERMAN
AYE FLOOR ARE NOT FIGHTING
ARAMBULA. BLOOM WHEN I BONTA
CHEN. NOT MANY CUNNINGHAM DALY
UNINVITING FONG. GIPSON GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE IRWIN- WHEN EILEEN
MCCARTY MEDINA. MEDINA AYE
MULLIN MULLIN AYE TANK WARD.
WEBER IRAQ. WE'LL LEAVE THAT
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER CHECK THINGS AND NEXT UP
WE WERE GONNA BE QUICKLY MOVED
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER COMMITTEE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO HAVE BILLS
LET'S START WITH SOME NUMBER
CHEN I REMEMBER FOR A B.
SEVENTEEN OH FOUR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR INDULGENCE- FOR
LIMITED PERCENT AB SEVENTEEN
ZERO FOUR. CURRENT LAW STATES IN
ORDER FOR INDIVIDUALS TO FORM X.
RAYS. OF THE LOCAL FOOT AND
ANKLE THEY WOULD NEED AT LEAST A
CALIFORNIA X. RAY TECHNICIAN
LIMITED PERMIT IN THE ALLEGE.
BUT HE ADDRESS CATEGORY. WELL
MORE EXTENSIVE X RAY PERMITS
MAY BE AVAILABLE THEY FAR
EXCEED. THE SCOPE OF IDOLATRY AS
SUCH DOCTORS OF PODIATRIC
MEDICINE HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
FIND EXTRA TAX ONE TO WORK IN
PODIATRIC OFFICE BE LIMITED TO
ONLY PERFORMING PODIATRIC
RADIOGRAPHY. THIS IS NOT A DIRE
SHORTAGE OF INDIVIDUALS.
AVAILABLE TO SYSTEM PERFORM X.
RAYS AND PUT ADDRESS OFFICES
WHICH CREATES A SITUATION THAT
HARMS INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL GROUP
PRACTICES ABILITY. TO PROVIDE
PROPER CARE. RESULTING ACT
EITHER NOT BE PER. REFERRED TO
OUTSIDE CENTERS OR OTHER IN FREE
MODALITIES BEING EMPLOYED THIS
ENDANGERS THE PUBLIC. ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM A. B. SEVENTEEN
ZERO FOUR ONE CREW THE PATHWAY
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO OBTAIN AND
LIMITED X. RAY PERMIT BUT I
TREATING. THE AUTHORIZING THE
PODIATRIC MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA AND A RADIOLOGIC
HEALTH BRANCH O JOINTLY-APPROVED. A NEW COMPREHENSIVE
COURSE THAT WILL PROBABLY TRAIN
THEM TO PERFORM THESE X. RAYS ON
SPECIALIZED. BRADRICK EXTRA
EQUIPMENT WITH BUILT IN SAFETY
FEATURES PACIFIC TO THE FOOT AND
ANKLE. HEREBY ARE PREVENTING THE
OVER CERTIFICATION TECHNICIANS
AND COURAGE TO FEEL THE PRIDE
TREE. QUALIFIED APPLICANTS. A
CURE TODAY TO TESTIFY IS DR
KHAIRUL AND DOCTOR CARRIED BALL
A CONDUCTED BALL. GREAT AND YOU
KNOW ARE THEY TESTIFYING BUT VIA
PHONE AT YES THIS IS ERIC GREAT.
THE OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR DR- RULE- WITH CDMA
SO THAT THEY CAN TESTIFY. THANK
YOU BOTH LINES ARE OPEN AND
AFTER APPROVAL PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ACTUALLY ALL DUE RESPECT PLEASE
DO NOT A DOCTOR BALL WILL GO
FIRST GO AHEAD THANKS. PLEASE
CLICK HERE- I AM OF REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA PODIATRIC MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION I'M A PRACTICING
PODIATRIST IN LOS ANGELES AND- I
AM A SERDES CAL- THE PRESIDENT
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY PUT
ENTERED MEDICAL ASSOCIATION- MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WE INCLUDING ENTERED
MEDICINE HAVE A PROBLEM AND WE
ARE NEED. ARE IN NEED OF YOUR
HELP. I THANK YOU FOR A LONG US
TO SPEAK DATE ADDRESS PROBLEM
WE'VE BEEN EXPERIENCING IN KOREA
YOUR OFFICES ACROSS THE STATE
AND THAT IS THE INABILITY TO
FIND ANY. QUAL AND- TO PERFORM
LIMITED X. RAYS OF THE FOOT AND
ANKLE. AT ANY GIVEN DAY IN A
PODIATRIC MEDICAL OFFICE ONLY
ABOUT 20% OF OUR PATIENTS
REQUIRE AN X. RAY THIS PROCESS
INVOLVES THE USE OF PLAIN X.
RAYS USING A TYPE OF DIGITAL
EQUIPMENT. WHICH IS SPECIFIC TO
THE FOOT AND ANKLE AND WHICH HAS
BUILT IN SAFETY FEATURES. MANY
OF THE COMMON TECHNOLOGIES WE
TREAT INCLUDING TRAUMA INFECTION
PRE AND POST SURGICAL CARE ALL
REQUIRE AN IMMEDIATE X. RAY
READINGS TO DETERMINE PROPER
TREATMENT. FAILURE TO OBTAIN AN
IMMEDIATE READ CAN DIRECTLY
AFFECT THE TRAJECTORY OF THOSE
PATHOLOGIES. WITHOUT QUALIFIED
STAFF AVAILABLE TO ASSIST US THE
REALITY OF TIME MANAGEMENT MOST
PODIA ETTRICK OFFICES MAKES IT
DIFFICULT OR IMPOSSIBLE FOR
PODIATRIST TO TAKE OUR OWN X.
RAYS EVEN THOUGH WE ARE
CERTIFIED BY THE RADIOLOGIC
HEALTH BRANCH. AS RADIOLOGY
SUPERVISORS AND OPERATORS THE
REALITY IS THAT ACTUALLY STUDIES
ARE EITHER AVOIDED ENTIRELY OR
SENT TO TERTIARY FACILITIES WITH
THE RESULTANT DELAY IN CARE. TO
ENSURE PATIENTS RECEIVE
IMMEDIATE CARE THEY NEED BUT I
CHRIS SEEK ASSISTANCE FROM
TECHNICIANS TO PERFORM IN OFFICE
X. RAY. THESE INDIVIDUALS OR
PODIA ETTRICK MEDICAL SYSTEMS
ARE DIFFERENT FROM OTHER
TECHNICIANS WHO PERFORM X. RAYS
IN THAT THEIR PRIMARY DUTY IS
CHAIR SIDE. WHAT NANGLE X. RAYS
ARE SECONDARY DUTY. IT COULD BE
MISSED. THE SIR X. X. SUCH AS
ONE MIGHT WORK CORPORATE GROUP
COULD BE UP HERE HOWEVER EVEN
IGNORE THE FINANCIAL. THAT THEY
COMMAND MUCH HIGHER SALARIES
THIS WOULD BE AN ERROR THOSE
EXTREMITY. UNDERSTANDABLY TO
PRACTICE THEIR FULL SCOPE SOLELY
AS RADIOLOGY TAX AND NOT AS
PRIMARILY MEDICAL ASSISTANCE.
WHICH WE NEED AB ONE SEVEN ZERO
FOUR TO BE ABLE TO TRAIN LIMITED
EXTRA TAX FOR PUT AN ANKLE. AS A
NEARING THE END OF MY TIME I
WOULD LIKE TO- YIELD TO MY THE
OTHER WITNESS DR KAREN RIBBLE
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH THERE
WAS NO TIME LEFT TO YIELD BUT
MS. DR. YOU GET TWO MINUTES. I
THANK YOU MY IS DR KAREN AND THE
PAST. OF THE COUNCIL PUT OUT
MEDICAL SO. AND THE AT YOUR BOY
AND I'M TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE- PRETTY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
. AND I'D LIKE TO ADD A BIT OF
HISTORY TO WHAT DOCTOR BALL
ALREADY SET. FOR DECADES PRIOR
TO TWENTY THIRTEEN OUR EXISTING
PODIA ETTRICK MEDICAL ASSISTANTS
WHO WISH TO INCREASE THEIR
SKILLS WITH TAKEN AVAILABLE
COURSE IN RADIATION TECHNIQUE
AND SAFETY WHICH WAS OFFERED
OVER SEVERAL WEEKENDS. AFTER
PASSING THE REQUIRED TEST WHICH
WAS DETERMINED BY THE ARCH B.
THEY WERE AWARDED CERTIFICATION
BY THE SAME ARE H. B. MANY OF
OUR A.'S TOOK THIS COURSE AND
INCREASE THE VALUE TO OUR
PRACTICES AND THEIR BY THEIR
SALARIES. IT WAS A GOOD SYSTEM.
BUT IN TWENTY THIRTEEN THE
REGULATION THAT ALLOWED THIS WAS
REMOVED IN ACCORDANCE WITH THAT
R. T. C. C. AND R. H. B. THE
ABILITY OF OUR M. A.'S TO BECOME
EDUCATED AS LIKE PUTTING A
TRICK. SIXTIES NO LONGER EXIST.
LEAVE NO SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA
OFFERING OR EVEN WILLING TO
OFFER COURSES IN THE SPECIFIC
LIKE PUT IT COUNTY. ALL NOW
THOSE LIKE PUTTING YOUR EX TWO
THAT CALL HAVE BEEN LAW TO A
TREE. AND IN FACT ONLY A HAND
REMAIN IN CAL. THIS IS CREATED A
CRISIS AND IS WHY WE COME TO YOU
RESTORATION TO THAT. SIMP PUT
THE PM'S CANNOT FIND X. P. WHO
ARE WE TO WORK AND PUT AT YOUR
OFFICE PERFORM ONLY FOOT AND
ANKLE RADIOGRAPHY. THEY JUST DID
NOT EXIST. REMOVE THE EXISTING
BEAR TO EDUCATION AND TO
ACCOMMODATE THE SPECIALIZED
EXCITING WE NEED TO SAFELY
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF QUALIFIED
AND APPROVED TECHNICIANS. BY
ADDRESSING OUTDATED IMPEDIMENTS
TO TRAINING AND EDUCATION WHICH
HAVE BECOME A DE FACTO
PROHIBITION. WE ARE SEEKING A
SOLUTION THAT WILL ENABLE THESE
INDIVIDUALS PARTICULARLY THOSE
ALREADY WORKING IN A PARTY AT
YOUR OFFICE. TO BE FURTHER
TRAINING PERMITTED TO PERFORM
THESE ACTS RIGHT AND W NEED
THAT SOLUTION SOON. AB SEVENTEEN
OH FOUR CREATES THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THAT SOLUTION AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
AND I HAVE ONE WITNESS PRIMER
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION A
PROFESSOR. DORIS ARBOR SUMMIT
BOB SHAMI. I WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGISTS- AND I DON'T SEE.
THE PROFESSOR IN THE ROOM SOME
GONNA HOPE THE PROFESSORS ONLINE
OPERATOR CAN YOU FIND PROFSSOR
ROBERT SHAMI. SO THAT THEY CAN
TESTIFY. THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR
DOOR TECHNICIANS I AM THE
DIRECTOR FOR THE BACHELOR OF
FINE IN GREATER LOGIC FIND THE
PROGRAM AT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY NORTHRIDGE I'M ALSO
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGISTS. AND ON BEHALF OF
THREE THIRTY I'M HERE TO STATE
OPPOSITE TO AB ONE SEVEN OH FOUR
UNLESS AMENDED I'VE WRITTEN AB
SEVENTEEN OH FOUR IN ASKING FOR
REMOVAL OF THE PERMITTING
PROCESS FOR LIMITED PERMITS.
FROM THE CURRENT REGULATORY
PROCESS THAT'S AVAILABLE AND
THEREFORE WILL HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES LEAVE CONSEQUENCES
WHICH REMOVES PODIA ETTRICK
LIMITED PERMIT CHEESE FROM THE
CURRENT REGULATORY PROCESS THAT
OVERSEES THE LIFE INSURANCE
SUPERVISOR AND THE EQUIPMENT
REGISTRATION WILL CONFUSE
OVERSIGHT AND ELIMINATE
ASSURANCE. THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE QUALITY
EDUCATION WHICH GIVE ASSURANCE
THAT THERE'S REGULATORY
PROTECTION OF THE CITIZENS. OF
CALIFORNIA. THE ARE CURRENT
PROCESSING IN PLACE. AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL TO AMERICAN
PEOPLEOF THE TECHNOLOGY OR A
FUNKY. WHICH PROVIDES CURRICULUM
CLINT COME THAT CAN BE IN. EACH
HEALTH. FOUR POINT CIRCLE
PERMITS COULD. OF CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA WE SHOULD NOT
IMPLEMENT THAT SYSTEM FROM A
PROFESSIONAL SOCIETY THAT IS NOT
AN EXPERT IN THE CURRICULUM
CONCORD YET JUST LIMITED
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU HAVE USED
THE AIR THIRTY CURRICULUM TO
MODEL ONLY LICENSE TECHNOLOGISTS
INTO REGULATIONS YOU SHOULD
AGAIN USE THE HIGH QUALITY MODEL
WE THEREFORE A COLD MAYBE
SEVENTEEN OH FOUR UNLESS IT'S
AMENDED TO INCORPORATE. THIS
QUALITY EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM INTO
REGULATION THIS IS THE ONLY WAY
TO AVOID THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. ADDITIONALLY LAST
WEEK THAT BUDGET COMMITTEE TWICE
EACH WEEK WHICH IS ALSO PART BY
PCC MADE OF THE FACT. AND
LEADERS OF IONIZING RADIATION
WHICH ALSO INCLUDES A PODIATRIST
PASSED THE MOTION THAT
RECOMMENDED TO DOLLAR TREE TO
CREATE A QUALITY EDUCATIONAL
PATHWAY USING HRT CURRICULUM FOR
THE LAKE YEAH ACTUALLY EXTRA. SO
THAT WE CAN MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE INTEREST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IT WOULD BE A
GREAT ROUTE TO TAKE IN ORDER TO
PROTECT CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA
AND TO ENSURE PUBLIC SELF
SAFETY. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
I'M HERE. AVAILABLE IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY-
IT WITH THAT I BELIEVE THAT'S
ALL THE PRIMARY AND OF LET'S GO
TO PRIMER IN SUPPORT OR ON HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM TODAY
ANYBODY WANNA AND WANTS TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN
THE HEARING ROOM. SEEING NINE IT
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES JUST
REMINDER NAME THE ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE WITH IF ANY AND SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION FOR A B. SEVENTEEN
OH FOUR OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
PHONE LINES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVENTEEN OH FOUR. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVENTEEN OH FOUR. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. NINE TO FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS DIæN
GARCIA I AM AT PASSED MEMBER OF
THE RADIOLOGIC CERTIFICATE
COMMITTEE RTC THREE FOR THE
RADIATION HEALTH BRANCH ARE PART
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH I AM FORTY FIVE
YEARS EXPERIENCE IN THE PRACTICE
RADIGRAPHY. PAST PRESIDENT-
ALSO ATTACKED PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGIST AS WELL AS THE PAST
PROGRAM DIRECTOR OF THE
DIAGNOSTIC MEDICAL. IMAGING
PROGRAM. ALLEN JUST AT THE GYM
OUT. I THE RHA. IS BUSY TO-
OVERSEE ALL OUR ACTION I'M THIS
BILL IS THE ONE COMMITTEE. OKAY
OKAY I THINK WHERE THE- SIMPLE
AS A SUB ABA FOR THE BILL. WE'VE
TAKEN THE PART WRONG WAY THIS IS
ABOUT THIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YES IT'S ACTUALLY NINE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. WORKING
OUT. RIGHT AT YOU HEAR ME YES I
CAN. THANK YOU- MY NAME IS A
NEED SELECT A I ANY PROCESS IN
THE REAR SCIENCE THAT CAN STATE
UNIVERSITY NORTH I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF OUR TCC THE RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGY CERTIFICATION
COMMITTEE WHICH IS THE ADVISORY
GROUP THAT VOTED ON THIS ISSUE
AND TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS-
LAST WEEK IN SACRAMENTO. UNLESS
AMENDMENT UNLESS MANDATE ME- IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AT NINE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SECURING MEMBERS BOB
BACKMAN HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
GREATER LOT BECAUSE- OF THE
DIALOGUE WITH YOUR AND- IN THE
MINIMUM ARE STEP IN THE RIGHT
TO. WE ALSO BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE
DONE WITHIN THE CONFINES OF OUR
H. B. AND WOULD RECOMMEND THAT
THOSE AMENDMENTS GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN Q.
AND- OR OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVENTEEN OH FOUR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BRING IT BACK TO COLLEAGUES
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON AB
SEVENTEEN OH FOUR STARTING ON MY
RIGHT. MOVING TO MY LEFT. THIS A
FULL- OBSERVE LED BY SHARE BUT
YOUR FLOOR THANK YOU CHAIR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AS THE- FOREIGN
BUYER FRIENDLY FIRE RATED THE
FORMER MEMBER OF TEAM USA
KICKBOXING I THINK YOUR
BRILLIANCE. AUTHOR TO BRING THIS
FORWARD SO I JUST WANNA THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PERSISTENCE AND- I
WOULD LOVE TO MAKE A MOTION MOVE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIR WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A
SECOND- ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SEEING NINE TO A
MISTER JOHN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE- IS THE BEAUTIFUL MISTER
HE FLOOR AND WONDERFUL
COMPLIMENTS IT HAD I JUST WANNA
SAY RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU MISTER UNDERSTAFFED THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU SLIMBRIDGE AND
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL I BELIEVE THE
AMENDMENTS AGREED TO IN HEALTH
COMMITTEE ALLEVIATED MANY OF THE
CONCERNS INCLUDING THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE CONCERNS. I HOPE THAT
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON THE REMAINING
CONCERNS RAISED TODAY- BUT WITH
THAT I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL- WE
HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A SECOND
MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN HI BERMAN HI FLORA. OR
AYE ARAMBULA. BLOOM BLOOM I
BONTA. CHAN CHEN AYE CUNNINGHAM
DALY DALLI AYE FONG. GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON- WHEN I WHEN
I LEE LEE I MCCARTY. MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN MULLIN AYE
TANG WARD. WEBER HOWEVER I. THAT
BILL IS OUT WITH A LOT OF VOTES
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS CONGRADULATIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MOVING ON IT I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY NOT ON THE
COMMITTEE SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA. YOUR UP AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB.
TWENTY THREE
FORTY ONE.
NOT QUITE CHAU MORE TIME. ABOUT
NOW. THE. IT'S ALL IT'S TO THE
LEFT OF THE PODIUM THIS MEDIA.
RIGHT WILL MAKE IT IS TRICKY AS
POSSIBLE HERE THERE WE GO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS. I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT A. B. TWENTY
THREE FORTY ONE THE FEDERAL AID
ACCESS FOR ALL ACT WHICH CLOSES
A LOOPHOLE ALLOWS ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. ACCESS THEIR FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID. STUDENT ACCESS TO
FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS
IS CRITICAL FOR STUDENTS TO
ACHIEVE THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
WELL CALIFORNIA HAS A CLEAR PATH
FOR MANY HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS TO MEET STATE
AUTHORIZATION REQUIREMENTS AND
OFFER FEDERAL AID TO THEIR
STUDENTS. THE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION EXCLUDES
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES ESTABLISHED
BY ANOTHER STATE. THIS IS THE
LACK OF CERTIFICATION BY THE
BUREAU THUS PREVENTS STUDENTS AS
INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS ARIZONA
STATE UNIVERSITY WHICH HAS A
PHYSICAL PRESENCE IN CALIFORNIA.
FROM ACCESSING MUCH NEEDED
FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID. AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY ONE WILL RECTIFY
THIS LOOPHOLE IN STATE POLICY A
LINE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WHO
ATTEND ANY PUBLIC INSTITUTION
CALIFORNIA THE ACCESS THE
FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID.
SPECIFICALLY AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY ONE AUTHORIZES THE BUREAU
FOR PRIVATE SECONDARY EDUCATION
TO ENTER A CONTRACT FOR THE
PURPOSES OF STATE AUTHORIZATION
THE PUBLIC INSTITUTION OF HIGHER
EDUCATION ESTABLISHED BY ANOTHER
STATE. THIS BILL WILL NOT CHANGE
THE QUALIFICATIONS FOR STATE
FINANCIAL AID- CAL GRANT. THE
BILL WAS THERE FOR CREEK WILL
THEREFORE CREATE PARITY AND
EXPAND ACCESS TO RESOURCES OF
ALL CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF THE INSTITUTION
THAT THEY ATTEND. HERE TO
TESTIFY N SUPPORT IS MAY
CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF ARIZONA
STATE UNIVERSITY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY
CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF ARIZONA
STATE UNIVERSITY PROUD TO BE
WORKING WITH MR MEDINA SR MEDINA
ON THIS BILL. I'M AS YOU AS A
LARGE PUBLIC UNIVERSITY THEY'VE
HAD A LONG HISTORY AND TIES TO
CALIFORNIA THEY HAVE ABOUT
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS THE STUDENTS RIGHT NOW
IN ABOUT. FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
ALUMNI- INCLUDING MYSELF SO I'M
PERSONALLY INTERESTED IN IN THIS
ISSUE AS WELL THEY ARE EXPANDING
THEIR OFFERINGS- FOR THE S. U.
CALIFORNIA CENTER WHICH IS IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES ON
BROADWAY. THEY'RE HOPING TO
PROVIDE MORE IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION TO THEIR STUDENTS- AT
THAT LOCATION THIS BILL WILL
REMEDY THIS STATE AUTHORIZATION
AUTHORIZATION ISSUE IDENTIFIED
WHERE UP CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE A
PROCESS FOR PRIVATE FOR
NONPROFITS FOR INDEPENDENCE- BUT
IF IT IS A PUBLIC UNIVERSITY-
ESTABLISHED BY ANOTHER STATE
WITH A PHYSICAL LOCATION IN
CALIFORNIA- OUR OUR STATE. CODE
DOES NOT AT REMEDY THE SITUATION
FOR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS TO BE
ABLE TO- HAVE ACCESS TO FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID LIKE PELL GRANTS
SO THAT IS THE ISSUE WE'RE
HOPING TO REMEDY WITH THIS BILL
AND WE- LOOK FORWARD TO EARNING
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- I DON'T HAVE ANY
PRIMER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
LET'S OPEN IT UP TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESS TESTIMONY IN THE HEARING
ROOM TODAY ANYONE IN THE ROOM
TODAY WHO WANTS TO ADD ON. IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE. I DON'T
SEE ANY SO IT'S OVER THE PHONE
LINES ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINES- WHO WANTS TO ADD ON. IN
IT'S A OR- OF A BEACH THREE
FORTY ONE IT NAME ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE WITH OF ANY. AND POSITION
ON THE BILL SUPPORT OR OPPOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. NINE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PETER
WEBSITE GOT THE VALLEY INDUSTRY
AND COMMERCE ASSOCIATION AND WE
SUPPORT AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT FOR NEXT MY NUMBER.
ALSO TAKE MOTIONS IN SECONDS
FROM COLLEAGUES. GOT A MOTION A
SECOND ONE MOMENT. I'M SORRY WE
DO HAVE A OF ONE MORE COMMENT
THAT'S GREAT NUMBER FIVE. FORTY
TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS- MY NAME IS TERRY SPENDING
AND AYE OPPOSED. A. B. TWO TWO
TWO THREE THANK YOU THAT ONE'S
COMING UP THIS AFTERNOON IN A
DIFFERENT COMMITTEE- BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT ANYBODY WHO
WANTS TO TESTIFY ON AB TWO THREE
FOUR ONE. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q. ON AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BRING IT BACK TO
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ABOUT THE MOTION IN THE
SECOND. COMING AROUND DON'T SEE
ANYONE. MR MEDINA WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU SIR THANK
YOU AS A MEMBER MEDINA IT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ARE
ELIGIBLE. FOR FEDERAL FINANCIAL
AID SO I AM HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY.WITH THAT MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE FLORA.
FLOOR AYE ARAMBULA. I AM. I AM I
BONTA. CHEN CAN I CUNNINGHAM.
DALLI VALLEY AYE FONG. GIPSON
IPSEN I GRAYSON- WHEN- WHEN I
LEE. MAY I MCCARTY INA MEDINA
AYE MULLIN MULLIN AYE TANG WARD
WEBER HOWEVER I. THAT BILL IS
OUT CONGRADULATIONS AND WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MR MEDINA
STILL SAYING NOBODY NOT ON THE
COMMITTEE LET'S GO TO SOME
RELIEF- AGENDA ITEM ELEVEN- A.
B.
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY TWO.
READY WHEN YOU ARE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WANT
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WITH I
WHICH WILL NARROW THE BILL TO
THE LIGHT FIXTURES BEING
INSTALLED OR REPLACED AFTER
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
AUDUBON SOCIETY 70% OF ALL BIRD
SPECIES MIGRATE EACH YEAR. OF
THOSE BIRDS 80% MIGRATE AT NIGHT
USING THE NIGHT SKY TO HELP THEM
NAVIGATE TO AND FROM THE
BREEDING GROUNDS EXCESSIVE
ARTIFICIAL LIGHT IS AFFECTING
ECOSYSTEMS AND CAN DISRUPT
CRITICAL BEHAVIOR IN WILDLIFE
THIS INCLUDES EXTRACTING NOT
NOCTURNAL MIGRATORY BIRDS AND
DIVERTING THEM FROM SAFE
MIGRATION ROUTES HUMAN VARMINTS
WHERE THEY ARE. MORE SUSCEPTIBLE
TO COLLISIONS WITH BUILDINGS AND
STRUCTURES. ARTIFICIAL LIGHT CAN
ALSO AFFECT INSECT MOVEMENT
FORGING AND REPRODUCTION WHEN
CAUGHT IN A WHITE PLUME OF A
LIGHT FIXTURE. THE CIRCLE AROUND
UNTIL THEY DIE THE LIGHT IS
EXTINGUISHED. EXCESSIVE
ARTIFICIAL LIGHTING ALSO HAS
DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS ON HUMANS.
TEENS AND ADOLESCENTS WHO LIVE
IN AREAS THAT HAVE HIGH LEVELS
OF ARTIFICIAL LIGHT AT NIGHT ARE
MORE LIKELY TO HAVE MOOD AND
ANXIETY DISORDERS. AS WELL AS
INTERRUPTED SLEEP PATTERNS. THE
INTERNATIONAL DARK SKY
ASSOCIATION ESTIMATES THAT AT
LEAST 30% OF OUTDOOR LIGHTING IN
THE UNITED STATES IS WASTED
PRIMARILY BY LIGHTS AREN'T
COVERED. THESE WASTE LIGHTS
TOTALED THREE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN LOSS OF
TRICITY COSTS EVERITT. AND
RELEASED TWENTY ONE MILLION TONS
OF CARBON DIOXIDE PER YEAR. THIS
BILL REQUIRE THAT ALL. OUTDOOR
LIGHTING FIXTURES INSTALLED OR
REPLACED ON STATE BUILDINGS AND
STRUCTURES AFTER JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. HAVE AN
EXTERNAL SHIELD TO DIRECT BILL
THE LIGHT TO WHERE IT IS NEEDED.
EQUIPPED WITH THE AUTOMATIC OR
SHUT OFF DEVICE. OR BE MOTION
ACTIVATED. THE CENTER FORM
PROMOTES SAFETY FOR MIGRATORY
BIRDS INSECTS AND PEOPLE.
THANKFULLY AFTER AYE VOTE. AND
TODAY I AM PLEASED TO BE JOINED
BY WINCES PORT NEILL DECIDE FROM
NATIONAL PARK CONSERVANCY
SITUATION AND JIM BANJA FROM THE
BANYA BURNETT CONSULTANCY. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WEBER
LIKE TO GO FIRST PLEASE DO TWO
MINUTES PER WITNESS- YEAH. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HOPE
YOU'RE ALL DOING WELL TODAY MY
NAME IS NEIL TO SIDE WITH THE
NATIONAL PARKS CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION. WE'VE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR THE PROTECTION OF
OUR NATIONAL PARKS AND OTHER
PUBLIC LANDS FOR OVER ONE
HUNDRED YEARS. WE THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEAVE FOR AUTHORING THIS
BILL IN THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS
CONSIDERATION OF IT. ARTIFICIAL
LIGHT AT NIGHT CAN HAVE WIDE
RANGING UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
FOR ECOSYSTEMS AND WILDLIFE. AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY TWO WORKS TO
ENSURE THAT OUTDOOR NIGHT
LIGHTING ON CERTAIN STATE
BUILDINGS AND STRUCTURES
FOCUSES. ON MEETING THE GOALS OF
LIGHTING WHILE REDUCING
UNINTENDED IMPACTS TO OUR
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT. THIS IS A
PROBLEM THAT WE ALREADY HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGIES AND CAPABILITIES TO
SOLVE IN AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
TWO PROVIDES. NEEDED DIRECTION.
ARE THE UNPRECEDENTED INCREASE
IN ARTIFICIAL LIGHTING AT NIGHT
IN CALIFORNIA AND GLOBALLY. IS
RESULTING IN THE DESTRUCTION AND
IN THE DAILY RHYTHMS AND
WILDLIFE- AS AUTHOR REFERENCE IN
HIS REMARKS. OF FOR EXAMPLE THIS
DAILY CYCLE OF LIGHT AND DARK IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR LIFE SUSTAINING
BEHAVIORS. SUCH AS REPRODUCTION
NOURISHMENT SLEEP AND PROTECTION
FROM PREDATORS ACROSS THE
ECOSYSTEM. FROM PLANTS AND
INSECTS TO AMPHIBIANS AND
MAMMALS SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A-
REALLY LARGE PORTION OF OUR
ECOSYSTEM- AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY TWO HELPS PROTECT OUR
NIGHT SKY IN BIO SPHERE. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. RIGHT ON YOUR SIR. YOUR
BERMAN I OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JAMES PENA I'M A
LICENSED PROFESSIONAL ELECTRICAL
ENGINEER RESPONSIBLE FOR
DESIGNING AND SPECIFYING
LIGHTING PROJECTS CALIFORNIA IN
THE NATION. I'M ALSO RECOGNIZED
AS AN EXPERT IN THE FIELD OF
LIGHTING AND SERVE AS AN EXPERT
CONSULTANT VARIOUS REGULATORY
LEGAL MATTERS ONE OF MY PARTNER
DEBORAH BURNETT IS HERE OUR
CONSULTING SERVICES EMPHASIZE
BEST PRACTICES IN ENERGY
CONSERVATION RESPONSIBLE
EXTERIOR LIGHTING CONSIDER THE
DARK SKIES LIMITING LIGHT
POLLUTION. AND ASSIST WITH
PUBLIC IN PUBLIC AND INDUSTRY
OUTREACH AND PROMOTING AWARENESS
BOTH THE BENEFITS AND THE
CONSEQUENCES OF ANTHROPOGENIC
BLIGHTED NIGHT. MY WORKING TITLE
TWENTY FOUR ENERGY CODE SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX HAS BEEN
TOWARDS THE GOAL OF ENSURING
LEGITIMATE NEEDS FOR LIGHTING
WITH MINIMUM IMPACT ON THE
COMMUNITY INTO THE NIGHT SKY.
TOTAL TWENTY FOUR A MAJOR CAUSE
FOR. OF COST EFFICIENT LED
LUMINAIRES CURRENTLY AVAILABLE
STATE WIDE FOR MY PROFESSIONAL
DESIGN EXPERIENCE IN VIRTUALLY
ALL TYPES OF OUTDOOR LIGHTING I
CAN. UNEQUIVOCALLY SAY THERE IS
NO COST DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
ORDINARY OUTDOOR LIGHTING AND
LIGHTING IS RESPONSIBLE TO THE
ENVIRONMENT AND HELPS MAINTAIN
THE NATURALLY DARK SKY.
EXTREMELY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
INTENT OF AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
TWO AND SOLUTION IF TOWARDS
PRODUCING STATEWIDE REGULATIONS
RESPONSIBLE INEFFICIENT OUTDOOR
LIGHTING. IN COORDINATION WITH
CALGARY. I SEE AB TWO TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY TWO IS THE NEXT
MAJOR STEP IN SEEKING TO REFINE
CLARIFY ENABLE PROJECTS ROAD
CALIFORNIA TO BECOME UNITED IN
PRESERVING DARKNESS AT NIGHT
CONSERVING ENERGY AND REDUCING
THE POTENTIAL FOR NEGATIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSEQUENCES. AND
WE HOPE TO PRESERVE THE MAJESTY
OF THE STARRY NIGHT SKY FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
BELIEVE WE HAVE JEFF AARON IT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA SIGN
ASSOCIATION- POSSIBLY TESTIFYING
AS AS THE MAIN OPPOSITION. VIA
PHONE OPERATOR IF YOU CAN
IDENTIFY JEFF AARON DOES IF THE
TIMING WORKS FOR HIM SO I'M NOT
SURE. IF THEY DID OR NOT WE'LL
FIND OUT. I DO NOT HAVE THAT
LINE AS A SPEAKER. OKAY WHY
DON'T WE MOVE ON AND IT MISTER
AARON IF YOU IF YOU SHOW UP- THE
SIGN IN AND WE'LL GIVE YOU TWO
MINUTES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. BUT WITH THAT LET'S
MOVE IT TO WITNESSES HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. TO AB. TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON. HI
MY NAME IS DEBORAH BURNETT. AS A
LICENSED DESIGN PROFESSIONALS.
IN ARCHITECTURAL DESIGN
PROFESSIONAL A MEMBER OF THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF SLEEP
MEDICINE. MY EXPERTISE IS IN THE
RESEARCH AND THE APPLICATION OF
HOUSE CIRCADIAN DYSREGULATION IS
BROUGHT TO BEAR THROUGH
ANTHROPOGENIC LIGHT AT NIGHT
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS
ARTIFICIAL LIGHT AT NIGHT AND I
SUPPORT A. B. TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY TWO LOVE IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEEING NINE ANY WITNESSES
THE PHONE LINES JUST A REMINDER
THIS IS FOR NAME ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE WITH IF ANY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR THE BILL.
OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE TO ONCE IT TO- TO ADD ON.
A IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB. TWENTY THREE EIGHTY TWO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY TWO. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY TWO.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
. NINE FOUR FORTY SEVEN. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO ABIGAIL MILE ON BEHALF OF
THE MID PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NINE SORRY. NINE FIVE FIFTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD DAY SIR BERMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SONNY KLEIN SMALL SPEAKING OF
THE HEALTHCARE CLARA OKAY
SOCIETY COULD OR THE BONE THE
AMERICAN BIRD. DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE THE CITIZENS COMMITTEE
TO COMPLETE THE RIGHT FIELD
CORNER LOVE OF ORNITHOLOGY GREEN
FOOTHILLS AND SAVE THE BAY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU HI SONNY AND.
THANKS FOR BEING SO EFFICIENT
WITH THAT. WE HAVE NO FURTHER.
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY TWO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SO WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO COLLEAGUES FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ON
THE BILL. GOT A MOTION. GOT A
SECOND NOT SEEING MANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS IS SOMEONE REALLY
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. I WAS A
FASTER AYE VOTE AND WORK ON THE
RULES IT. THANK YOU FOR
FOLLOWING THE RULES IS ONLY
MEMBER LEE. I COULD HELP BUT
NOTICE I WAS LOOKING AT THE THAT
LISTEN SUPPORT I THOUGHT ALL
THESE ARE ALL GROUPS IN MY
BACKYARD IS REALLY INTELLIGENT
OF YOU AND I REALIZE WE
REPRESENT THE SAME AREA. SO IT
ALSO MAKES A LOT OF SENSE. AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO WORK WITH STATE
AGENCIES AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENSURE THAT THE BILL DOES DEEP.
DOES NOT DUPLICATE OR CONFLICT
WITH EXISTING REGULATIONS
RELATED TO LIGHT POLLUTION
REDUCTION- I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY. AND ALEX PLEASE
CALL THE VOTE. MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN AYE BERMAN
AYE FLORA. ARAMBULA I AM I AM I
BONTA. CHEN CHEN AYE CUNNINGHAM
AND HIM I DALLI DALLI AYE FONG.
IPSEN GIPSON AYE GRAYSON R. ONE-
WHEN EILEEN BY MAY I MCCARTY
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN. ONE I
ATTAIN WARD WEBER IRAQ THAT BILL
IS OUT WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR TWO MORE
COLLEAGUES SERVERS THEIR BILLS
ONE IS CURRENTLY PRESENTING IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE AND THEN WILL
HEAD RIGHT OVER HERE THE OTHER
IS MIA SO IF ANYBODY SEES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY GRAB HIM
AND DRAG HIM OVER TO WHATEVER
ROOM MORE AND- ELEVEN HUNDRED.
YEAH YEAH THAT'S ABSOLUTELY- I
DON'T.
SO WE'RE GONNA BAG GIVE
COLLEAGUES AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADD
ON THE BILLS THEY THEY MISSED
THAT'S THE START OF THE TOP WITH
AGENDA ITEM ONE AND SCROLL
THROUGH UNTIL WE GET- AND BUT-
ELKS YOU'LL START WITH CONSENT
DO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ON CONSENT NOT A MOTION AND
SECOND MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
BERMAN HI BERMAN I FLOOR FLOOR
AYE ARAMBULA BLOOM BLOOM I BONTA
CHAN CHAN I CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. DALI L. A. I. FONG
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON. IRWIN
BERMAN EILEEN. MAY I MCCARTY.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN. MULLIN
AYE TANG. WARD WEBER. HOWEVER I. THAT BILLS OUT I CAN THINK
CALENDARS OUT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OF TRAPS AND MEMBERS- NOW
LET'S START. AT THE TOP I
BELIEVE THIS WAS WHEN WE WERE IN
A SUB COMMITTEE SO I THINK FOR
AGENDA ITEM ONE WE NEED A MOTION
AND SECOND IS THAT RIGHT THAT IS
RIGHT. FOR MOTION AND SECOND FOR
AB TWENTY NINETY EIGHT. OUR
MOTION. GOT A SECOND. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE FLORA. OR
NO ARAMBULA. BLOOM M. I. BONTA
GEN CAN NOW CUNNINGHAM I AM NOW
DALLI DALLI NOW FONG. IPSEN
IPSEN I GRAYSON IRWIN IRWIN
EILEEN MAY I MCCARTY MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN MULLIN AYE
TANG WARD. WEBER HOWEVER I.
WE'LL KEEP THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS- NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY TWO
NOPE THAT WAS ON CONSENT- I'M
NUMBER THREE DID WE HAVEN'T
MOTION MULLIN. WE A MOTION NEED
. AND A SECOND FOR. I REMEMBER
THREE WE HAVE MOTIONS AND
SECOND- MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
VOTE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. FOR AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY SIX WEBER BERMAN HI
BERMAN AYE FLORA FLOOR AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM.
LAMB I BONTA CHAN CHAN I
CUNNINGHAM AND HIM AYE DALLY
DALLI AYE FONG. FONG I GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON. R. ONE- WHEN
I LEE. THE AYE MCCARTY MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN MULLIN AYE
TANG WARD WEBER. HOWEVER I THAT
BILL IS OUT WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE
OF AN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- NOW
THIS IS RANDOM. IS THERE ARE
SOME ALREADY JUST LET ME KNOW
WHEN WE GET ON. GREAT YOU KNOW.
YEP AB SEVENTEEN OH FOUR- BLOOM
. M. I. BONTA. FONG FONG I
MCCARTY WARD THANK. I CUNNINGHAM
I AM I THINK. GREAT. THE NEXT OF
HIS AGENDA ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE WE NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND FOR THIS
BILL. GOT A MOTION THE SECOND MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
I FLOOR. FLOOR AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM. WHEN I
BONTA. CHAN CHAN ICUNNINGHAM. I
AM I DALLI. DALLI AYE FONG. FONG
AYE GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
R. ONE. R. ONE EILEEN. MAY I
MCCARTY. MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN. ONE AYE TANG WARD. WEBER
HOWEVER I THAT BILL IS OUT WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. YEAH AB NINETEEN OH ONE
IS AREA IN. LARA OR NOW BLOOM.
WHY AM I BONTA. CUNNINGHAM MEET
HIM NOW. GIPSON GIPSON HI ME. WE
AYE MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN. MULLIN AYE TANE WARD.
THAT BILL IS OUT WE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. A. B.
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR QUIRK. LARA. FOUR HI LUME. M. I. BONTA.
CUNNINGHAM AND HIM AYE GIPSON
GIPSON HI LEE THE AYE MCCARTY.
MULLIN MULLIN AYE TANG. THE BILL
HAS ALREADY OUT WELCOME STILL IN
THE ROLE ABSENT FROM SOME
MEMBERS. IN AB TWO ZERO SIX ZERO
CORK ARAMBULA. AND BLABBING.
BONTA CUNNINGHAM. NUMBER GIPSON
. GIPSON HI WE MAY I MCCARTY.
THANK. THE BILL HAS ALREADY OUT
IT STILL IS WILK STILL KEEP IT
OPEN FOR US MEMBERS. AB TWENTY
EIGHTY SEVEN. PETRIE-NORRIS
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI BONTA.
CUNNINGHAM AM I WRONG. FONG NO
GIPSON GIPSON HI LEE LEE I
MCCARTY. THANG WARD. OR I. THAT
BILL IS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE OF
THE PRESIDENT BUT WILL THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- ADAMS-
YEAH THAT. AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
ONE MEDINA. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
AYE BONTA. CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
I. FONG. FONG I GRAYSON. MCCARTY
THANK WARD RIGHT I. THE BILL WAS
ALREADY OUT IT'S STILL OUT. AND
ALSO LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ADAMS. AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY TWO LEE.
LARA R. I. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I
BONTA. FONG FONG I GRAYSON.
MCCARTY THING THING I WARD OR I. THAT BILL WAS ALREADY OUT
STILL IS STILL OPEN FOR ADAMS.
IN THAT IS. THE FIRST PASS
THROUGH THE BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED THERE WILL BE A SECOND
PASS ANOTHER PASS. IS HOPEFUL
EVAN WILL GET HERE AND THEY CAN
VOTE. WE'RE LOOKING FOR. HOLDEN
IN MCCARTY IF MCCARTY STAFF IS
HERE I'M HAPPY YEAH WE'RE GOOD
LET'S DO IT I'M GONNA GO PRESENT
MISTER MCCARTY'S BILL AND TURN
IT OVER TO VOICE YOUR FLOOR. A
SECOND VERY SHORT WASN'T ASIAN.
MISTER CHAIR WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MISTER TURN MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
THIS BILL TODAY THE CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ADDRESSING
COMPLAINTS ABOUT CONTRACTORS BY
PUBLICLY DISCLOSING DETAILS OF
MINOR COMPLAINTS AND LETTERS OF
ADMONISHMENTS FOR ONE YEAR FROM
THE DATE THE LETTER IS SERVED.
AB TWENTY NINE SIXTEEN WOULD
EXTEND SOME OF THE PUBLIC
DISCLOSURES OF MINOR COMPLAINTS
AND LETTERS OF ADMONISHMENT TO
TWO YEARS BACK SPENT EXTENDING
THE TIMELINE THIS WILL PROVIDE
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY TO
CONSUMERS AND INCREASE CONSUMER
PROTECTION CONSUMER PROTECTION
IS BEST SERVED WHEN THE PUBLIC
HAS ACCESS TO RECORDS OF
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS TAKEN BY
THE BOARD. ADDITIONALLY
ADDITIONALLY THE PUBLIC
DISCLOSURE PERIOD FOR LETTERS OF
ADMONISHMENT IS SIGNIFICANTLY
SHORTER THAN ADMINISTRATIVE
CITATIONS WHICH IS A PERIOD OF
FOUR YEARS WITH ME TODAY
TESTIFYING BY PHONE IS ROB FONG
FORMER CITY COUNCIL MEMBER I'M
ASSUMING OF SACRAMENTO KNOWING
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL AND
WHITNEY FONG. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE LET ME QUICKLY
CHECK WITH THE CONSULTANT DO I
NEED TO ACCEPT AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL. YES I WILL I'M HAPPY DOES
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL- THAT THE CHAIR WAS SO WISE
IN SUGGESTING- AND WITH THAT
LET'S. MOVE IT TO THE WITNESSES
FOR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL GO TO FIRST WRITTEN
ROBERT WHITNEY FONG BY PHONE.
THANK YOU HIGH- MY NAME IS ROB
FONG IS THE- AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTIONED- I AM NOT A-
FORMER CITY COUNCILMEMBER SURE
INSTEAD SACRAMENTO AND- JUST
WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW THAT- IN
MY WIFE'S CAR BUT THE COMPANY
ATTORNEYS WE WENT THROUGH AN-
EIGHT. MONTH THE THAT TOOK TWO
AND A HALF YEARS. OF THE JOB IS
NOT FINISHED CONTRACTOR WALKED
OFF THE JOB STUDENTS BOB
MECHANICS NEED AND- YOU KNOW WE
ARE NOT LAWSUIT FOR THREE YEARS
AND SO. HOMEOWNERS REALLY NEED
MORE PROTECTIONS FROM HOME
REMODELING CONTRACTORS  JOB.
CONSUMERS DON'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND UPON THIS AREA WE'RE
BOTH ATTORNEYS AND WE DIDN'T.
ONCE WE MOTHER STARTS WORK ON
YOUR HOME THE HOMEOWNER WILL BE
AT THE MERCY OF THE CONTRACT
ESPECIALLY IN TERMS OF TIMELINE
AND COST SO. YOU KNOW MOST
CONSUMERS DON'T KNOW THAT IT'S
AGAINST MARK REQUEST PAYMENTS
FOR WORK BEFORE IT'S DONE WE
DIDN'T- MANY CONTRACTORS DON'T
COMMIT A SUBMIT WRITTEN CHANGE
ORDERS ON JOBS AND MOST
CONSUMERS DON'T KNOW THAT THIS
IS REQUIRED BY LAW SO. YOU KNOW
MANY MANY CONTRACTORS DO NOT
ACTUALLY AVERAGE AND UNDER THE
BOARD TO PUT THE CONTRACT SO. WE
WILL BE IN. OF THIS OF THIS BILL
EIGHT TWENTY NINE SIX IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION ANYTHING
THE CS BEACON YOU TO CALL. PUT
CONCERN FROM CONTRA. IS THE
STORE NEEDED AND- THERE'S JUST
LOT OF PEOPLE OUT OF WORK OUT IN
THE WORLD AND STUFF. REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU CAN THIS TAKING
THE- WITH YOU. THANK YOU MUCH.
THAT'S WHAT THE ON THE PHONE
PLEASE. IN SUPPORT. HI WHAT MADE
BY I'M ROB WIFE I'M SORRY ALL
THE WAY I DIDN'T HEAR EVERYTHING
HE SAYING I'VE TAKEN A LOOK AT-
THE PROPOSAL IS AB. NINE SIXTEEN
AND THE ONE THAT I HAVE TO SAY
IS IN MY WORK WITH A LOT OF
CONTRA- WE A BRAND THREE MODEL
SITUATION BUT I ALSO PUT HOME
AND YOU WERE. THEY ARE. I
SEARCH- BY ALMOST ANY. AT THE
CFL. R. BY NAME BY THANK. NUMBER
BY LICENSE NUMBER. THE PEOPLE
OFTEN CHANGE THEIR NAMES THEIR
BUSINESS NAMES THEIR PERSONAL
NAME. HAVE BEEN ACTION HE
AGAINST- AND WAY TO OUT OF
FUTURE COSTS FIND THAT
INFORMATION AGES FREE REGISTER
UNDER DIFFERENT SAME- I
UNDERSTAND THAT BOB THIS
PARTICULAR SOLUTION DOESN'T
ADDRESS STOPS BUT WHAT IT DOES
THE DRIVE. IS ALLOWING EVIDENCE
OF DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS TO BE ON
THEIR FILE FOR AT LEAST TWO
YEARS I'M NOT SURE WHY IT
WOULDN'T BE PERMANENT I
UNDERSTAND THAT EXTENSION. FROM
ONE YEAR TO TWO YEARS IS VERY
HELPFUL BOB AS AN ATTORNEY AND A
MEMBER OF THE STATE FARM ANY
DISCIPLINARY ACTION TAKEN
AGAINST THAT THE- ON OUR FILE
FOR OUR LIFELINE BECAUSE
RELEVANT INFORMATION. THAT THE
CONSUMER NEEDS AND NOW SO I
THINK THE FACT THAT ANY ACTION
TAKEN AGAINST THE CONTRACTOR
AGAIN WE'RE NOT HERE HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH CHANGING THE
STANDARDS OF REVIEW OR CHANGING-
THE STANDARD FOR DISAPPOINTING
THE CONTRACTOR THIS IS JUST ONE
THE SEATTLE HAVE DECIDED TO. THE
CONTRACTOR IF SOMETHING FUTURE
CONSUMER CONCERN AGAIN LIKE I
SAID CONTRACTORS A PROFESSIONAL
THAT HE BEATING THOSE SEARCHES I
GOT FRIENDS OF MINE NOT BE ABLE
TO FIND INFORMATION ON THE
CONTRACTOR HIRING ONLY LATER TO
DISCOVER THAT THERE WAS
DISCIPLINARY ACTION TAKEN
AGAINST THEM. THAT THEY COULDN'T
FIND WHEN THEY SEARCH A
PARTICULAR NAME OR LIKENESS. ON
THAT HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
HARMING THE CONTRACTOR TO
EDUCATING UNEDUCATED PUBLIC AND
ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
TRANSACTION THE VERY WHITE WERE
ARGUABLY THE NEED THE MOST FOR-
I THINK IT'S A START OBVIOUSLY
WE DON'T THINK IT'S ENOUGH IF A
CONTRACTOR. THOUGHT THE OF BEING
DISCIPLINE WHICH IF YOU KNOW THE
PFLP TAKE LOT BECAUSE THEY
NEGOTIATE AND BARGAIN LIKE A
CRIMINAL COURT IF DISAPPOINTED
ACTUALLY TAKEN THE PUBLIC NEEDS
TO KNOW ABOUT IT IT'S INDICATIVE
ABOUT CONTRACTORS INTEGRITY
ABILITY TO PERFORM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
BY THE PHONE. THINGS JUST TO
NAME AN ORGANIZATION. AS MIKE TO
MAKE SKI. I DO NOT HAVE THAT
LINE ON THE PHONE AT THIS TIME
NO PROBLEM MOVING THE OPPOSITION
I HAVE NON ON NO OPPOSITION ON
FILE IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINES.
BUT A MODERATOR ANY OPPOSITION
ALONG WITH. THERE ARE NO
SPEAKERS QUEUED UP FOR THE PHONE
LINES THANK YOU SO MUCH BRING ME
TO COURT. NO WE'RE OKAY WILL
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM
ANY SUPPORTER OPPOSITION THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. C. NINE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. XENON MISTER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST WANNA SAY
THANKS MY WITNESSES- TESTIFYING
AS A REFORM ATTORNEY MYSELF WHO
ALSO NEEDS TO DO HOME REMODEL- I
APPRECIATE THEM HOPEFULLY MAKING
THE PROCESS BETTER FOR ALL OF US
IN THE FUTURE RESPECT AFTER AYE
VOTE WELL THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING YOUR AMENDMENTS-
MISSING A POLITICAL- PARDON THE
INTERRUPTION. MISTER. MAY WE
HAVE- WE DO HAVE A FEW COMMENTS
ON THE PHONE LINE- EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL MAKE A QUICK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NINE THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU I THINK YOU IT MIGHT
CHEN MEDICAID CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD CHAIR MEMBER IF
THE- EVENT SUPPORT ADDS PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME ON A BEACON NINE
ONE SIX THANKS. THANK YOU. NINE
THREE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO AGAIN MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA I UNDERSTAND
IT'S NOT THE BILL THAT YOU GUYS
ARE TALKING ABOUT BUT I'M THANK
YOU SO MUCH MOVING UNTIL TWENTY
NINETY EIGHT. HELLO THAT'S WHAT
THE SAND AT. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
BUT THE SECOND A PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN. BERMAN
AYE FLORA FLOOR I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM. HELLO I
BONTA. CHEN CAN I CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. DALLI DALLI AYE
FONG. FONG MIKE GIPSON. GIPSON
AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE IRWIN-
WHEN I LEAN THE AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY NOT VOTING MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN MULLIN AYE
TANG. TANG I WARD. MARIN AYE
WEBER HOWEVER I. THAT BILL IS
OUT AND WE WILL LEAVE THE
THAT BUTTON YEAH OKAY. IT'S NOT
INTUITIVE
DELIVER WRITTEN REPORT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
DCA DESCRIBING THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. SURROUNDING A
PHYSICAL ALTERCATION WITH A
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC BY
REGISTERED PROPRIETARY PRIVATE
SECURITY OFFICERS ACTING WITHIN
THE SCOPE OF THEIR EMPLOYMENT
WITHIN SEVEN BUSINESS DAYS AFTER
THE QUALIFYING INCIDENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE VERY CONCISE
PRESENTATION AND I BELIEVE
YOU'VE GOT WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT. YES RIGHT HELLO MISTER
CHAIRMAN- AND MEMBERS KELLY
JENSEN REPRESENTING CAL SAGA L.
SAGER OF THE REPRESENTS OVER-
TWO ONE IN TEN OF SECURITY
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING. EIGHTY THOUSAND
SECURITY GUARDS- WE HAVE A
PLEASURE WORKING WITH HIM MR
HOLDEN LAST YEAR ON HIS AB TWO
TWO NINE THIS IS AN EXTEND-
EXTENSION OF THAT IN A
HARMONIZATION OF THOSE TOO-
BILLS AS IT RELATES TO
PROPRIETARY SECURITY GUARDS AND
CONTRACT SECURITY GUARDS AS FOR
YOUR- SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
PRIMER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
SEEING NONE ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I DON'T
THINK I HAVE ANY ON MINE. SHEET
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WHO WANT TO ADD ON IN
THE HEARING ROOM TODAY. SEEING
NINE ANY WITNESSES WHO WANT TO
ADD ON IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE LINES AND A
REMINDER. IS FOR NAME
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH IF ANY
AND POSITION ON THE BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTEEN. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTEEN. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME GREAT BRING
IT BACK TO COLLEAGUES WE HAVE A
MOTION WE HAVE A SECOND DO WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ARE NUMB ALL RIGHT. MOVING TO MY
LEFT. NOT SEEING ANY. YOUR WHOLE
WE LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL. WE ARE
MOTION. YEAH READ MORE YEAH
PLEASE CALL VOTE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED MANY AND
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
I FLORA AYE LORE AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA BLOOM BLOOM I BONTA.
GEN CAN I CUNNINGHAM. DALLI
DALLI AYE FONG. I GIPSON GIPSON
AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE IRWIN-
WHEN I LEE ME I'M CO. MEDINA
MEDINA MULLIN MULLIN AYE TANG.
AYE WARD WORD I WEBER WEBER HI
THAT BILL IS OUT WE WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
TO ADD ON CONGRATULATIONS MISTER
HOLDEN- AND THAT IS THE LAST
BILL PRESENTATION WE HAVE TODAY
I KNOW WE HAVE SOME FOLKS NEED
TO ADD ON THE BILLS- WHO HAVE
WRITTEN.
JUST A NOTE TO EVERYBODY WE'RE
GONNA KEEP IT IN- COMMITTEE
HEARING OPEN FOR TEN MINUTES FOR
PEOPLE THAT FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO COMING OUT ON THE
BILLS TEN MINUTES SO TWELVE
ELEVEN MINUTES TWELVE TEN IS
WHEN WE'RE GONNA GAVEL DOWN- SO
WHY DON'T WE OR EARLIER IF
YOU'LL GET A EARLIER WE CAN
ALWAYS YOU EARLIER- MISTER
SECRETARY WELL WE START FROM THE
TOP TO ALLOW MEMBERS TO ADD ON
THE BILL'S INVOKES THE MISSED.
ON IT THEY ALL HAVE AYE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE CHAIR
FOR ANYONE IS CURIOUS. I ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BONTA. FONG FONG I
GRAYSON AND MCCARTY. TEN IN AYE
WARD OR NOT. AB TWO ZERO NINE
EIGHT LOW ARAMBULA. IT JUST WALK
OUT. BONTA FONG. FONG NOW
GRAYSON IT'S NOT VOTING. MCCARTY. TEN TEN AYE WARD WORD I. SIR
TWENTY NINETY EIGHT IS OUT WIL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
OUT ON. AB SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX
WEBER BONTA GRAYSON. GRAYSON I.
WARD OR AYE TANG AYE.
AB SEVENTY NOW FOR CHEN. GRAYSON
GRAYSON I. THANK IN AYE WARD
WHAT I. AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
KALRA. GRAYSON GRAYSON I THINK
IN AYE WARD WORD I. AB NINETEEN
OH ONE AS AERION- TANG. I.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR QUIRK
TANG. AND I. AB TWENTY SIXTY
EIGHT CORK TAINT AND I. AB TWO
ZERO EIGHT SEVEN PETRIE-NORRIS.
THANK AND I. AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY ONE MEDINA. THANK AND I
GRAYSON GRAYSON I. AB. TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY TWO. LEE- GRAYSON
GRAYSON I.
I DON'T. MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL A VOTE ON THE BILLS SO
THERE'S LESS CHIT CHAT AND MORE
VOTING THIS WEARING. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR BONTA. BONTA HI
MCCARTY HI MCCARTY AT TWENTY
NINETY EIGHT LOW BONTA I BONTA
I'M MCCARTY I. FIFTEEN THIRTY
SIX WEBER BONTA AYE BONTA AYE
MCCARTY AYE AB SEVENTEEN OH FOUR
CHAN. BONTA I ON TIME MCCARTY I
. AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE KALRA
BOND I BONTA I'M MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I AB NINETEEN NO ONE IS
AERION BONTA AYE BONTA AYE
MCCARTY. MCCURRY I A. B.
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR A QUICK
BONTA. I BONTA I MCCARTY MCCARTY
I AB TWENTY SIXTY QUIRK BONTA
AYE BONTA AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY I
. AB TWENTY EIGHTY SEVEN
PETRIE-NORRIS BONTA I BONTA I.
MCCARTY MCCARTY I. AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY ONE MEDINA BONTA AYE
BONTA AYE MCCARTY CARI I. AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY TOO LEAN
BONTA AYE BONTA AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY I. AB TWENTY FIVE ONE
FIVE HOLDEN BONTA I BONTA AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY. A. B. TWENTY
NINE SIXTEEN MCCARTY BONTA. I
BONTA HI MCCARTY. MCCARTY I ONTO.
ALL RIGHT THAT'S IT FOR THE
HEARING THINGS ARE ON.